Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. The evening of Sunday, March 22, 1970, five months after the murder of Paul Stein in San Bernardino, California. Kathleen Jones was preparing for a long road trip. The 22-year-old was visiting her sick mother in Petaluma, a seven-hour drive away. Kathleen, who was seven months pregnant, preferred to make this familiar journey at night.
我们的剧集涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。1970年3月22日星期日晚上，在加利福尼亚州圣贝纳迪诺保罗·斯坦被谋杀五个月后。凯瑟琳·琼斯正在准备一次长途旅行。这位22岁的年轻人要去佩塔卢马探望她生病的母亲，车程需要七个小时。当时怀孕七个月的凯瑟琳更喜欢在晚上进行这段熟悉的旅程。
There were fewer people on the roads and the car's engine would allow her 10-month-old daughter to sleep. Kathleen got into her 1957 Chevrolet and set off with her daughter strapped into the backseat. By 11.45pm, Kathleen was driving along the Interstate 132 Highway in Patterson. She glanced up at her rear view mirror. A late-model, light tan-colored car was trailing close behind her. It was being driven by a white male wearing black-framed eyeglasses. He flashed his headlights, trying to get Kathleen's attention. Kathleen ignored the man and he soon sped up and overtook her. Nervous that something might be wrong with her vehicle, she decided to pull over and check,
路上的车比较少，汽车引擎的声音能让她10个月大的女儿安睡。凯瑟琳坐进她1957年的雪佛兰，带着系在后座的女儿出发了。晚上11点45分，凯瑟琳正沿着帕特森的132号州际公路行驶。她抬头看了看后视镜。一辆新款的浅棕色汽车紧跟在她后面。驾驶它的是一名戴着黑框眼镜的白人男性。他闪烁着前大灯，试图引起凯瑟琳的注意。凯瑟琳没有理会那个人，他很快加速超过了她。因为担心车辆可能出了问题，她决定靠边停车检查，
just in case. Noticing this, the man promptly braked, then backed up to meet her by the side of the highway. Speaking in a slow, monotonous voice, he explained that her left rear wheel had been wobbling. He offered to fix it, and Kathleen accepted. Kathleen accepted. The man fetched a wrench and knelt by Kathleen's wheel for a couple of minutes, tightening the lug bolts. He then stood up and told her she was all set to continue. He strolled back to his car and drove away, without saying another word. Kathleen started her engine and pulled away from the roadside. But within moments, her car came to a grinding halt.
以防万一。注意到这一点，那名男子立即刹车，然后倒车在高速公路旁与她会合。他用缓慢而单调的声音解释说，她的左后轮一直在晃动。他主动提出修理，凯瑟琳接受了。凯瑟琳接受了。那名男子拿来一把扳手，在凯瑟琳的车轮旁跪了几分钟，拧紧了凸耳螺栓。然后他站起来告诉她，一切都修好了，可以继续上路了。他慢悠悠地走回自己的车并开车离开，没再说一句话。凯瑟琳发动引擎，从路边驶离。但没过多久，她的车就发出刺耳的摩擦声停了下来。
She got out to see what was wrong. The left rear tire had almost completely fallen off, with only one bolt still holding it in place. The man who'd made the repairs was still close enough to see that Kathleen had a problem. He promptly returned to the scene and offered to drive her to the nearest service station for professional assistance. Kathleen agreed and gathered up her infant daughter, leaving her keys in the ignition and the headlights on. She then climbed into the front passenger seat of the man's vehicle, holding her daughter on her lap. The car's interior was a mess, with clothing, rubbish and children's toys scattered about. After continuing along the highway for some time, the man eventually took an exit that led down some
她下车查看出了什么问题。左后轮胎几乎完全脱落，只剩一颗螺栓还在固定着它。那个进行修理的男子离得足够近，能看到凯瑟琳遇到了麻烦。他立即回到现场，主动提出开车送她去最近的服务站寻求专业帮助。凯瑟琳同意了，抱起她年幼的女儿，把钥匙留在点火开关里，大灯也开着。然后她抱着女儿坐进了那名男子汽车的前排乘客座位。车内一片狼藉，到处散落着衣服、垃圾和儿童玩具。在高速公路上行驶了一段时间后，那名男子最终驶入了一个出口，通往一些
quiet country roads. Kathleen was relieved to see a service station in the distance, but the man drove straight past it, without so much as pausing. They soon passed more service stations and the same thing happened again and again. Confused, Kathleen finally asked the man why he wasn't stopping. He simply explained that none of the service stations were right, then changed the subject. By this point they'd been driving around for about an hour and a half, but the man showed no signs of finding help as promised. Hoping she was just being paranoid, Kathleen continued making small talk.
安静的乡村道路。凯瑟琳很高兴看到远处有一个服务站，但那名男子直接开了过去，连停都没停。他们很快又经过了更多的服务站，同样的事情一次又一次地发生。凯瑟琳感到困惑，终于问那名男子为什么不停下来。他只是解释说那些服务站都不合适，然后转移了话题。此时他们已经绕着开了大约一个半小时，但那名男子并没有表现出要按承诺寻找帮助的迹象。凯瑟琳希望自己只是多疑了，于是继续闲聊。
The man told her that he worked for two months of the year, then spent the rest of his time driving around, mostly at night. Kathleen asked if he spent his long drives helping many people who found themselves in trouble. The man simply replied, When I get through with them, they don't need any help. Kathleen was now terrified, certain that the man planned to harm her in some way. When he pulled up at a stop sign, she saw an opportunity. Gripping her daughter in her arms, Kathleen flung open the door and jumped from the vehicle. She raced into a nearby field as fast as she could. The man made no attempt to stop her.
那名男子告诉她，他一年只工作两个月，其余时间都在开车，大部分是在晚上。凯瑟琳问他是否在长途驾驶中帮助过许多陷入困境的人。那名男子只是回答说：“当我处理完他们时，他们就不需要任何帮助了。”凯瑟琳现在非常害怕，确信那名男子计划以某种方式伤害她。当他在停车标志前停下时，她看到了一个机会。凯瑟琳紧紧抱着女儿，猛地推开车门跳了出去。她以最快的速度冲进附近的田野。那名男子没有试图阻止她。
Instead, he simply reached over, closed the passenger door, and turned his lights off. He sat stationary in the dark for approximately five minutes, before flicking his lights back on and driving away into the night. Kathleen lay down flat on the ground. It was pitch black and she had no idea where she was. It appeared she had run into a vineyard and was in an irrigation ditch surrounded by tall grass. After the man left the area, Kathleen's first instinct was to return to the road. She clambered up an embankment and stood near the bottom of a hill by the roadside, waiting for a car to come by. A semi-trailer approached and Kathleen frantically flagged it to
相反，他只是伸手关上乘客车门，关掉了车灯。他在黑暗中静止坐了大约五分钟，然后重新打开车灯，驶入夜色中。凯瑟琳平躺在地上。周围漆黑一片，她不知道自己在哪里。看起来她跑进了一个葡萄园，正待在被高草包围的灌溉沟里。在那名男子离开该地区后，凯瑟琳的第一反应是回到路上。她爬上路堤，站在路边山脚下，等待车辆经过。一辆半挂卡车驶来，凯瑟琳疯狂地挥手示意它
stop. The driver hit the brakes. Kathleen's relief was soon overcome with anxiety. She eyed the semi-trailer's male driver with apprehension and begged him not to come any closer. Despite being her only means of escape, she didn't want to get into another car with another male stranger and put herself, her daughter, and her unborn baby in potential danger. Eventually, a female driver arrived on the scene and offered to help. The woman drove Kathleen and her daughter back to Patterson and dropped them outside the town's police station. It was around 2.30 am. Almost three hours had passed since Kathleen's ordeal began. She was visibly distraught and it took officers some time to calm her down.
停下。司机踩下了刹车。凯瑟琳的如释重负很快被焦虑所取代。她忧心忡忡地打量着半挂卡车的男司机，恳求他不要再靠近。尽管这是她唯一的逃生手段，但她不想再坐上另一个陌生男子的车，让自己、女儿和未出生的孩子陷入潜在的危险。最终，一名女司机来到现场并主动提供帮助。这名女子开车将凯瑟琳和她女儿送回帕特森，并将她们放在了镇警察局外。当时大约是凌晨2点30分。距离凯瑟琳的磨难开始已经过去了近三个小时。她明显心烦意乱，警官们花了一些时间才让她平静下来。
Eventually, she was able to provide a statement about the night's events. Just as she concluded her story, Kathleen noticed a nearby bulletin board. She began screaming. The attending officer asked what was wrong. Kathleen pointed at a piece of paper pinned to the bulletin board and said, that's the man. My God, that's the man who picked us up. The officer looked to see what she was pointing at. It was a wanted poster featuring two composite sketches of the Zodiac killer. Kathleen couldn't remember exactly where she'd left her vehicle,
最终，她能够就当晚发生的事件提供一份陈述。就在她讲完故事时，凯瑟琳注意到附近的公告栏。她开始尖叫。在场的警官问她怎么了。凯瑟琳指着贴在公告栏上的一张纸说：“那是那个人。天哪，那就是带走我们的那个人。”警官看向她指的地方。那是一张通缉海报，上面有两张“黄道十二宫杀手”的合成素描。凯瑟琳记不清她把车停在哪里了，
but a deputy was dispatched to the general area on the lookout for the 1957 Chevrolet. As he traveled two miles east of Interstate 5, he noticed a gray smoke emanating from a spot up ahead. It was coming from Kathleen's vehicle. Someone had set it on fire and the car was still smoldering. All that remained was an empty, burned out shell. Although Kathleen had said her left rear wheel was tampered with, an examination of the wreckage showed it was actually the right side. Back at the Paterson police station, interviewing officers began to wonder about Kathleen's story. It had been five months since the Zodiac's last known attack, and they had been waiting with nervous anticipation for him to make his next move.
但一名副警长被派往该区域寻找那辆1957年的雪佛兰。当他行驶到5号州际公路以东两英里处时，他注意到前方某处冒出灰色烟雾。烟雾来自凯瑟琳的车。有人放火烧了它，车子还在冒烟。剩下的只有一具空荡荡、烧焦的残骸。虽然凯瑟琳说她的左后轮被动了手脚，但对残骸的检查显示，实际上是右侧。回到帕特森警察局，负责审讯的警官开始怀疑凯瑟琳的故事。距离“黄道十二宫”上一次已知的袭击已经过去了五个月，他们一直怀着紧张的期待等待他采取下一步行动。
Kathleen's ordeal didn't fit with his typical ammo, as he had never abducted a victim for a considerable length of time. But it was possible he had changed his approach once again. Yet, with each retelling, Kathleen added small details and new claims that varied from the original. She said the man took her car keys, but they were still in the ignition and returned to Kathleen after her car was towed. Initially, she also said the man refused to stop, then later clarified that he had stopped at one service station, but it was closed. Complicating matters further was the fact that Kathleen never actually asked the man to stop or let her go. Because of this, police wondered whether the incident could technically be qualified as a kidnapping.
凯瑟琳的遭遇与他典型的作案手法不符，因为他从未长时间绑架过受害者。但有可能他再次改变了方法。然而，随着每一次复述，凯瑟琳都增加了一些与最初版本不符的小细节和新说法。她说那名男子拿走了她的车钥匙，但钥匙其实还在点火开关里，并在她的车被拖走后归还给了凯瑟琳。起初，她还说那名男子拒绝停车，后来又澄清说他在一个服务站停过，但那里关门了。更复杂的是，凯瑟琳实际上从未要求那名男子停车或放她走。正因如此，警方怀疑该事件在技术上是否能被定性为绑架。
Over time, Kathleen's story became more embellished, as she added that the man had repeatedly threatened to kill her. After her opportunistic escape, he stepped out of the car to look for her with the flashlight. Police hoped to verify Kathleen's story with the woman who had driven her to Patterson. But Kathleen hadn't asked for her contact information. A few weeks after Kathleen's encounter, a group of friends in San Francisco were chatting when they realized none of them had seen or heard from their friend Robert Salem in several days. On April 19, they decided to check in on him. They let themselves into the apartment in the mid-market district where 40-year-old Robert lived alone. To their shock, his lavishly
随着时间的推移，凯瑟琳的故事变得越来越夸张，她补充说那名男子曾多次威胁要杀死她。在她趁机逃脱后，他下车用手电筒寻找她。警方希望通过那名送她去帕特森的女子来核实凯瑟琳的故事。但凯瑟琳没有索要她的联系方式。在凯瑟琳遭遇后的几周，旧金山的一群朋友在聊天时意识到，他们中已经有好几天没见过或听过朋友罗伯特·塞勒姆的消息了。4月19日，他们决定去看看他。他们进入了罗伯特独自居住的中市场区公寓。令他们震惊的是，他那豪华的
furnished home was in total disarray. Draws had been upended, and Robert's belongings were strewn everywhere. The place had been thoroughly ransacked. In the middle of the chaos was Robert, sprawled on a couch. The white jumpsuit he was wearing was covered in blood. He had been stabbed five times in the back, once in the chest, and his throat had been slashed. Robert's left ear was also missing. As his friends cast their eyes upwards, the sight before them grew even more shocking. Scrawled on a wall in Robert's own blood were the words, Satan save Zodiac, followed by a crosshair symbol. Despite the message tying the murder to the Zodiac, detectives were quick to rule out any
住所一片混乱。抽屉被翻了个底朝天，罗伯特的财物散落得到处都是。这个地方被彻底洗劫了。在混乱的中心，罗伯特瘫倒在沙发上。他穿着的白色连体裤上沾满了血迹。他的背部被刺了五刀，胸部被刺了一刀，喉咙也被割开了。罗伯特的左耳也不见了。当他的朋友们抬头看时，眼前的景象更加令人震惊。在罗伯特自己的血迹中，墙上潦草地写着“撒旦拯救黄道十二宫”，后面跟着一个十字准星符号。尽管这条信息将谋杀案与“黄道十二宫”联系起来，但侦探们很快排除了任何
connection. Nothing about the crime matched the Zodiac's MO. Investigators theorized that the culprit's motive was robbery, and they staged the scene in an attempt to throw police off their path. They were right. Months later, a 22-year-old man named Stanley Dean confessed to the crime while under investigation for another unrelated murder. Detective David Toskey lived and breathed the Zodiac case. The homicide inspector for San Francisco's police department had originally fronted the investigation into Paul Stein's murder. Once the Zodiac took responsibility for the cabbie's death, Toskey and his partner William Armstrong went in hard to identify the notorious serial killer. Toskey was a notable character at San Francisco's PD. In contrast to the
关联。犯罪的任何细节都不符合“黄道十二宫”的作案手法。调查人员推测，罪犯的动机是抢劫，他们伪造了现场，试图将警方引入歧途。他们是对的。几个月后，一名叫斯坦利·迪恩的22岁男子在因另一起无关的谋杀案接受调查时承认了这起罪行。大卫·托斯基侦探全身心地投入到“黄道十二宫”案件中。这位旧金山警察局的凶杀案调查员最初负责保罗·斯坦谋杀案的调查。一旦“黄道十二宫”对出租车司机的死亡负责，托斯基和他的搭档威廉·阿姆斯特朗就全力以赴去查明这位臭名昭著的连环杀手。托斯基是旧金山警察局的一位著名人物。与
dark, plain-colored clothing worn by his colleagues, Toskey stood out in colorful suits and bow ties. He embraced his position as the public face of the Zodiac case. A softly-spoken, friendly man, Toskey worked tirelessly with police departments in other jurisdictions to collate all the Zodiac information and to begin the mammoth task of piecing it together. They focused on the suspect's known features, his physical appearance, the fact that he committed crimes in locations named after bodies of water, his mention of having a basement which very few homes in California possessed, the possibility that he had a military background. Several details alluded to this. Firstly, the Zodiac was known to wear wing walker boots associated with the Air Force. In one of his letters,
同事们穿着深色、素色衣服不同，托斯基总是穿着色彩鲜艳的西装和领结，显得格外引人注目。他欣然接受了自己作为“黄道十二宫”案件公众形象的地位。托斯基是一位说话轻声细语、待人友好的男士，他与其它司法管辖区的警察部门不知疲倦地合作，整理所有关于“黄道十二宫”的信息，并开始进行将它们拼凑在一起的艰巨任务。他们专注于嫌疑人的已知特征，他的外貌，他在以水体命名的地点犯罪的事实，他提到拥有地下室（加利福尼亚很少有房屋拥有地下室），以及他可能有军事背景的可能性。几个细节暗示了这一点。首先，“黄道十二宫”以穿着与空军有关的“翼行者”靴子而闻名。在他的一封信中，
he'd talked about coating his fingertips with aeroplane cement, which indicated another possible Air Force link. He'd also used a bayonet-style knife in one of his killings, a weapon commonly linked to the US military. After fleeing the scene of Paul Stein's attack, the Zodiac had fled into the Presidio Park area, which was a former United States Army post. Toskey familiarized himself with all the Zodiac correspondence. Then on April 20, 1970, he received an unopened letter that had originally been sent to the San Francisco Chronicle. Addressed to the editor, the newspaper staff recognized the handwriting on the envelope immediately and forwarded it to police without opening it. Inside was a letter that began. This is the Zodiac speaking. A question followed.
他谈到用飞机胶水涂抹指尖，这表明了另一种可能的空军联系。他在一次杀戮中还使用了一把刺刀式刀具，这是一种通常与美国军队有关的武器。在逃离保罗·斯坦的袭击现场后，“黄道十二宫”逃进了普雷西迪奥公园地区，那里曾是美国陆军驻地。托斯基熟悉了所有“黄道十二宫”的通信。然后，在1970年4月20日，他收到了一封未拆封的信，这封信最初是寄给《旧金山纪事报》的。信封上写着致编辑，报社工作人员立即认出了信封上的笔迹，并在未拆封的情况下将其转交给警方。里面是一封以“我是黄道十二宫”开头的信。随后是一个问题。
By the way, have you cracked the last cipher I sent you? The answer was no. No one had yet cracked the Zodiac killer's previous cipher, known as the 340. His letter continued. My name is the sentence ended abruptly. A 13-character line of symbols followed. It was another cipher. Then, switching back to plain English again, the Zodiac pondered. I am mildly curious as to how much money you have on my head now. He denied responsibility for a pipe bomb blast that occurred months earlier at the Golden Gate Park police station, while simultaneously claiming that he'd recently tried to detonate a bomb on a bus. His plans had been thwarted by heavy rain. If he'd succeeded, he said, his death toll would be even higher than the 10 lives he said he'd taken
“顺便问一下，你破解我寄给你的最后一个密码了吗？”答案是否定的。还没有人破解“黄道十二宫”杀手之前的密码，即“340”。他的信继续写道：“我的名字是……”句子戛然而止。后面跟着一行13个字符的符号。那是另一个密码。然后，再次切换回简单的英语，“黄道十二宫”思索道：“我有点好奇，现在你们悬赏我的钱有多少了。”他否认对几个月前发生在金门公园警察局的管状炸弹爆炸事件负责，同时声称他最近试图在一辆公共汽车上引爆炸弹。他的计划因大雨而受阻。他说，如果他成功了，他的死亡人数将比他声称已经夺走的10条生命还要多
thus far. Included with the letter was a hand-drawn diagram of this supposed bomb, along with the words, PS. I hope you have fun trying to figure out who I killed. The letter was signed with the crosshair, along with the letter's SFPD for San Francisco Police Department, an equals sign, and the number zero. In his previous letter, the Zodiac had mentioned seven victims. Now he was claiming he'd killed 10. Investigators only knew of five. David Faraday, Betty Lou Jensen, Darlene Farron, Cecilia Shepard, and Paul Stein. Either he had killed more people than the police were aware of, which would be unusual given his desire to take credit for his crimes, or he was inflating his kill count to either confuse police
到目前为止。信中附有一张这个所谓炸弹的手绘图，以及这样的话：“附言：希望你们在试图弄清楚我杀了谁时玩得开心。”信的结尾签着十字准星符号，以及代表旧金山警察局的“SFPD”字母、一个等号和数字零。在他之前的信中，“黄道十二宫”提到了七名受害者。现在他声称已经杀了10个人。调查人员只知道五个人：大卫·法拉第、贝蒂·卢·詹森、达琳·法伦、塞西莉亚·谢泼德和保罗·斯坦。要么他杀的人比警方知道的要多，考虑到他渴望为自己的罪行邀功，这很不寻常；要么他是在夸大杀人数量，要么是为了迷惑警方，
or increase his notoriety. The 13-symbol cipher was sent to cryptologists, but ciphers shorter than 30 characters are generally considered unsolvable, as numerous solutions can be derived from them. Without further input from the killer, the code was deemed too difficult to decipher, and the Zodiac's identity remained a mystery. Despite his apparent desire to be identified, the Zodiac went to great lengths to avoid this happening. His handwriting, while distinct and recognizable, often varied in minute detail. The letter D was always in cursive, and his Rs appeared like check marks. Police believed he was disguising his genuine handwriting so as not to give himself away.
要么是为了增加他的恶名。这13个符号的密码被送到了密码学家手中，但少于30个字符的密码通常被认为是无法破解的，因为可以从中推导出无数种解决方案。在没有杀手进一步输入的情况下，该代码被认为太难破解，“黄道十二宫”的身份仍然是一个谜。尽管他显然渴望被识别，但“黄道十二宫”还是竭尽全力避免这种情况发生。他的笔迹虽然独特且可辨认，但往往在细微之处有所不同。字母D总是用草书书写，而他的R看起来像勾号。警方认为他是在伪装自己真实的笔迹，以免暴露身份。
Given the Zodiac's claim that his bomb attempt was swamped out by the rain, an investigation was launched into lower-lying regions of the San Francisco Bay Area. If police could find the spots where the rainwater pooled, they might be one step closer to locating the killer. When denying responsibility for the police station bombing, the Zodiac had written, it just wouldn't do to move in on someone else's territory. Did this indicate the Zodiac had a specific area that he considered his turf? Whatever the case, the My Name Is letter was well examined and its points thoroughly explored,
鉴于“黄道十二宫”声称他的炸弹袭击因雨水而受阻，一项针对旧金山湾区低洼地区的调查随即展开。如果警方能找到雨水汇集的地方，他们可能离定位杀手更近了一步。在否认对警察局爆炸案负责时，“黄道十二宫”写道：“侵入别人的地盘可不太好。”这是否表明“黄道十二宫”有一个他认为是自己地盘的特定区域？无论如何，“我的名字是”这封信得到了很好的检查，其要点也得到了彻底的探索，
but detectives failed to achieve any major breakthroughs. Reports on the matter ended with the bleak remark. The investigation continues. A little over a week later on April 28th, the Zodiac's threats escalated when he sent a cartoon greeting card to the Chronicle. It featured an image of a small man riding a donkey, alongside another small man riding a dragon. Printed above the image was the caption, sorry to hear your arse is a dragon.
但侦探们未能取得任何重大突破。关于此事的报告以一句凄凉的话结束：“调查仍在继续。”一周多后的4月28日，“黄道十二宫”的威胁升级了，他寄给《纪事报》一张卡通贺卡。上面画着一个小人骑着驴，旁边是另一个小人骑着龙。图片上方印着标题：“听说你的屁股是一条龙，很遗憾。”
This pre-printed message appeared to be a play on words, which the Zodiac was employing to mock the police's slow investigation. In the Zodiac's handwriting was a more personalized note, warning of how he was finally intending to carry out his bomb threat. It read, I hope you enjoy yourselves when I have my blast. There were two ways that the blast could be avoided, the Zodiac added. 1. The Chronicle was to publish details about his plans to blow up a bus. 2. He wanted to see the people of San Francisco wearing Zodiac themed badges.
这条预先印好的信息似乎是一个双关语，这是“黄道十二宫”用来嘲笑警方缓慢的调查。在“黄道十二宫”的笔迹中，有一条更个性化的注释，警告他最终打算如何实施他的炸弹威胁。上面写着：“希望你们在我引爆时玩得开心。”“黄道十二宫”补充说，有两种方法可以避免爆炸。1.《纪事报》要公布他炸毁公共汽车计划的细节。2.他想看到旧金山的人们佩戴“黄道十二宫”主题的徽章。
The San Francisco Police Department instructed the Chronicle to run a brief article about the card in order to placate the Zodiac. They were certain this latest note was genuinely from him, due to the bomb threats which had also been made in previous Zodiac letters. 3. The Case Detectives had always been careful to keep those references under wraps out of fear they may cause unnecessary panic. 4. On May 31, law enforcement made the difficult decision to publicize the bomb threat. 5. Suddenly the risk felt too great. 6. It was 5.28 am on June 19, 1970, when the sound of gun shots rang out over Waller Street in San Francisco's Lower Haight neighborhood. There were three shots in total, fired in quick
旧金山警察局指示《纪事报》刊登一篇关于这张卡的简短文章，以安抚“黄道十二宫”。他们确信这张最新的便条确实来自他，因为之前的“黄道十二宫”信件中也曾提到过炸弹威胁。3.案件侦探一直小心翼翼地将这些参考信息保密，以免引起不必要的恐慌。4.5月31日，执法部门做出了公开炸弹威胁的艰难决定。5.突然间，风险感觉太大了。6.1970年6月19日凌晨5点28分，枪声在旧金山下海特社区的沃勒街上响起。总共开了三枪，接连
succession. Officers were dispatched to the area after receiving a call from a concerned citizen. They pulled up to the block between Scott and Peer Streets, where they found a stationary patrol car. The car's interior was soaked with blood and its sole occupant, 25-year-old traffic patrolman Richard Raditich, was slumped over towards the passenger seat, barely clinging to life. Raditich had been preparing to run a check on a parked car, when a bullet fired from a .38 caliber pistol hit him in the head, as he was still gripping his police microphone. Just as one of the attending officers exited the vehicle to take a closer look, a neighbor leaned out of a nearby window and shouted,
发射。在接到一位关心此事的市民的电话后，警官们被派往该地区。他们停在斯科特街和皮尔街之间的街区，发现了一辆停着的巡逻车。车内浸满了鲜血，唯一的乘员，25岁的交通巡警理查德·拉迪蒂奇，瘫倒在乘客座位一侧，生命垂危。拉迪蒂奇正准备检查一辆停着的车，这时一颗从.38口径手枪发射的子弹击中了他的头部，当时他手里还握着警用麦克风。就在其中一名在场警官下车查看时，一位邻居从附近的窗户探出头来大喊：
Get down, they might still be around. The officer quickly ducked down and waited for back up to arrive. Soon, the area was swarming with police. Although no one had seen the shooting, witnesses reported seeing a white Cadillac speeding away from the area seconds after the shots were fired. Officer Raditich was rushed to the hospital, but later died of his injuries. His colleagues had no idea who could have killed him, and urged anyone who knew anything about the crime to come forward. As the days ticked by, the people of San Francisco remained on edge, wondering when or where the Zodiac would strike next.
“趴下，他们可能还在附近。”警官迅速蹲下，等待增援部队到达。很快，该地区到处都是警察。虽然没有人看到枪击事件，但目击者报告说，在枪声响起几秒钟后，看到一辆白色凯迪拉克飞速驶离该地区。拉迪蒂奇警官被紧急送往医院，但后来因伤势过重死亡。他的同事们不知道是谁杀了他，并敦促任何了解该罪行的人挺身而出。随着日子一天天过去，旧金山的人们仍然处于紧张状态，想知道“黄道十二宫”接下来会在何时何地发动袭击。
Despite their fears, they ignored his request to wear badges that acknowledged his demands. As schools closed for summer vacation, there was a sense of relief throughout the city. At least there would be no school buses on the roads for the killer to target. Almost two weeks passed with no reported attacks. Then, on Monday, June 29, another suspicious envelope arrived at the offices of the Chronicle. It had all the hallmarks of a Zodiac letter, except that, unlike those before it, this one wasn't specifically addressed to the editor. Inside was a map of San Francisco with the location marked in the Mount Diablo area.
尽管他们感到恐惧，但他们还是无视了他佩戴承认其要求的徽章的请求。随着学校放暑假，整个城市都感到一丝宽慰。至少路上不会有校车让杀手作为目标了。近两周过去了，没有发生袭击报告。然后，在6月29日星期一，另一封可疑的信件抵达了《纪事报》办公室。它具有“黄道十二宫”信件的所有特征，只是与之前的信件不同，这一封没有专门写给编辑。里面是一张旧金山地图，上面标出了迪亚布罗山地区的位置。
The isolated peak sat to the east of the Bay Area, and was one of California's most iconic landmarks, attracting hikers, birdwatches, and nature lovers. The map was accompanied by a letter that read, This is the Zodiac speaking. I have become very upset with the people of San Friend Bay Area. They have not complied with my wishes. I promised to punish them if they did not comply by annihilating a full school bus. But now school is out for the summer, so I punished them in another way. I shot a man sitting in a parked car with a 38. The map coupled with this code will tell you where the bomb is set. You have until next fall to dig it up. At the end of the letter were 32 coded characters.
这座孤立的山峰位于湾区东部，是加利福尼亚州最具标志性的地标之一，吸引了徒步旅行者、观鸟者和自然爱好者。地图附有一封信，上面写着：“我是黄道十二宫。我对旧金山湾区的人民感到非常不满。他们没有遵守我的意愿。我承诺如果他们不遵守，我就惩罚他们，炸毁一辆满载的校车。但现在学校放暑假了，所以我用另一种方式惩罚了他们。我用一把.38口径手枪射杀了一个坐在停着的车里的人。这张地图加上这个密码会告诉你们炸弹设置在哪里。你们有到明年秋天的时间把它挖出来。”信的末尾有32个编码字符。
Alongside the Zodiac's crosshair symbol was the number 12, next to the letters, SFPD equals 0. The killer was now claiming he'd murdered 12 people, while investigators were no closer to catching him. The latest cipher was sent to the FBI, but experts were unable to crack the code. Nor were any fingerprints detected on either the letter, map, or envelope. However, the handwriting was a match to the previous letters, confirming it to be genuine Zodiac correspondence. Investigators reflected on the Zodiac's claim of having shot a man in a car with a 38 caliber weapon. The only recent crime that matched this description was the fatal shooting of patrolman Richard Raditich. The scene of the shooting was just two and a half miles
在“黄道十二宫”的十字准星符号旁边是数字12，旁边是字母“SFPD=0”。杀手现在声称他已经谋杀了12个人，而调查人员离抓住他并没有更近一步。最新的密码被送到了联邦调查局，但专家们无法破解该代码。在信件、地图或信封上也没有检测到任何指纹。然而，笔迹与之前的信件相符，证实这是真正的“黄道十二宫”通信。调查人员反思了“黄道十二宫”声称用.38口径武器射杀车内男子的说法。最近唯一符合这一描述的罪行是巡警理查德·拉迪蒂奇被枪杀案。枪击现场距离
from where the Zodiac had killed Cabby Paul Stein. And the Zodiac had recently boasted of killing police members in a letter, writing, There is more glory in killing a cop than a kid. Because a cop can shoot back. However, several days after officer Raditich was shot, a witness reported seeing an ex-convict named Joe Johnson driving away from the scene, and police thought he was a likely suspect. They'd already issued an APB for Johnson's arrest, and didn't believe that the Zodiac was involved in any way. Charges against Johnson were later dropped due to a lack of evidence. Although the authorities remained dubious about the Zodiac's confession, they couldn't confirm or deny whether he was responsible for the young officer's murder.
“黄道十二宫”杀害出租车司机保罗·斯坦的地方只有两英里半。而且“黄道十二宫”最近在一封信中吹嘘杀害警察成员，写道：“杀警察比杀孩子更有荣耀。因为警察会还击。”然而，在拉迪蒂奇警官被枪杀几天后，一名目击者报告说看到一名叫乔·约翰逊的前科犯从现场开车离开，警方认为他是一个可能的嫌疑人。他们已经发布了逮捕约翰逊的通缉令，并不认为“黄道十二宫”以任何方式参与其中。针对约翰逊的指控后来因证据不足而被撤销。尽管当局对“黄道十二宫”的供述仍持怀疑态度，但他们无法证实或否认他是否应对这名年轻警官的谋杀负责。
One month passed with no further word or action from the Zodiac. Then, on July 27, another letter arrived at the Chronicle, in which the Zodiac again complained that people weren't wearing Zodiac themed badges. Angered, he said he now had a little list of people he planned to kill, starting with a woman and a baby whom he'd given a rather interesting ride a few months prior. He claimed that the encounter had ended with him torching their car. Case detectives believed the woman he was referring to was Kathleen Johns, and the reference appeared to confirm her suspicion that the man who'd tampered with her vehicle and set it alight was the Zodiac killer. But they also had to consider the possibility
一个月过去了，“黄道十二宫”没有进一步的消息或行动。然后，在7月27日，另一封信抵达了《纪事报》，其中“黄道十二宫”再次抱怨人们没有佩戴“黄道十二宫”主题的徽章。他愤怒地说，他现在有一份他计划杀死的人的小名单，名单上第一个就是几个月前他曾载过一程的女人和婴儿。他声称那次遭遇以他烧毁他们的车而告终。案件侦探认为他指的是凯瑟琳·琼斯，这一提及似乎证实了她的怀疑，即那个动了她车并放火烧车的人就是“黄道十二宫”杀手。但他们也必须考虑这种可能性：
that the Zodiac had simply read Kathleen's account in the news and decided to take credit. A second, much longer letter also arrived at the Chronicle that same day. In it, the Zodiac threatened to torment the souls of his victims if his requests continued to be ignored, outlining various torture methods in graphic detail. Once again, he alluded to having a little list of intended victims. The Zodiac's repeated use of this phrase was a reference to a song from a Gilbert and Sullivan opera called The Mikado. The character who sang this song was known as Coco, the Lord High Executioner, and he wore a hood very similar to the one the Zodiac had donned for the Lake Berryessa attack. To ensure this connection wasn't missed, the Zodiac had
“黄道十二宫”只是在新闻中读到了凯瑟琳的叙述，并决定冒领功劳。同一天，第二封更长的信也抵达了《纪事报》。在信中，“黄道十二宫”威胁说，如果他的要求继续被忽视，他将折磨受害者的灵魂，并以图形细节概述了各种酷刑方法。他再次暗示自己有一份预定受害者的小名单。这一短语的反复使用是对吉尔伯特与萨利文歌剧《天皇》中一首歌的引用。唱这首歌的角色被称为“可可”，即最高执行官，他戴着一个兜帽，与“黄道十二宫”在伯耶萨湖袭击中戴的兜帽非常相似。为了确保这种联系不会被错过，“黄道十二宫”
written a parody of the song, describing the types of people he planned to target next. His lyrics concluded with the chilling words, But it really doesn't matter whom you place upon the list. For none of them be missed, none of them be missed. Detectives believed this second more detailed illusion indicated he was worried his earlier reference may have been misinterpreted. Convinced this must be significant, they wondered whether he may have performed in the Mikado, either during school or in an amateur production. They looked into drama troops that were staging the Mikado during the time of the
写了一首这首歌的模仿作品，描述了他计划接下来针对的人群。他的歌词以令人不寒而栗的话结尾：“但把谁放在名单上真的没关系。因为他们都不会被错过，他们都不会被错过。”侦探们认为这种第二次更详细的暗示表明，他担心他之前的引用可能被误解了。确信这一定很重要，他们想知道他是否曾在学校或业余演出中表演过《天皇》。他们调查了在
Zodiac attacks, but these inquiries led nowhere. While this letter featured the Zodiac's usual spelling errors, its tone was more bizarre than the others. Some investigators speculated that his mental state was deteriorating, while others wondered if this was just a ruse to trick them into believing he was insane. In any case, his threats felt increasingly empty. It appeared to detectives that the Zodiac was now more interested in seeking attention through words than actions. Editors at the Chronicle felt that the Zodiac had been too encouraged by all of the media attention. Consequently, they decided not to publish any excerpts from these last two letters. The Zodiac no longer appeared to be committing any attacks, and the emptier his
“黄道十二宫”袭击期间上演《天皇》的剧团，但这些调查毫无结果。虽然这封信有“黄道十二宫”通常的拼写错误，但其语气比其他信件更怪异。一些调查人员推测他的精神状态正在恶化，而另一些人则想知道这是否只是为了诱骗他们相信他疯了的诡计。无论如何，他的威胁感觉越来越空洞。侦探们认为，“黄道十二宫”现在对通过言语而不是行动寻求关注更感兴趣。《纪事报》的编辑们认为，“黄道十二宫”受到了所有媒体关注的过度鼓励。因此，他们决定不发表这两封信的任何摘录。“黄道十二宫”似乎不再进行任何袭击，而且他的
threats sounded, the less interested readers were in his letters. The evening of Sunday, September 6, 1970, 11 months after the murder of Paul Stein in South Lake Tahoe, California. 25-year-old Donna Lass settled in for her night shift at the Sahara Hotel Casino in South Lake Tahoe. She was employed as the on-site nurse, and it was her duty to tend to any patrons who required basic medical assistance. It was a relatively new job, as Donna had only recently moved to South Lake Tahoe from the Presidio area of San Francisco. Her shift that night was fairly ordinary and ended without incident. Donna eventually clocked off and disappeared into the night.
威胁听起来越空洞，读者对他的信件就越不感兴趣。1970年9月6日星期日晚上，在加利福尼亚州南太浩湖保罗·斯坦被谋杀11个月后。25岁的唐娜·拉斯在南太浩湖的撒哈拉酒店赌场开始了她的夜班。她受雇担任现场护士，职责是照顾任何需要基本医疗援助的顾客。这是一份相对较新的工作，因为唐娜最近才从旧金山的普雷西迪奥地区搬到南太浩湖。她那天晚上的轮班相当普通，没有发生任何意外。唐娜最终下班，消失在夜色中。
The following day, the phone rang at the Sahara Hotel Casino. One of Donna's co-workers answered. A man on the other line said he was a relative of Donna's and explained there had been an illness in the family. Consequently, Donna wouldn't be able to make it to work. Her employer made note of her absence and assumed she'd soon return. But Donna didn't show up for her next shift either and had made no further contact. Now concerned, her employer notified the police. They paid a visit to Donna's apartment, finding her 1968 convertible parked out the front. Inside, her apartment was spotless. Donna's clothes and credit cards were still there, and a check of her bank account revealed it hadn't been touched.
第二天，撒哈拉酒店赌场的电话响了。唐娜的一位同事接了电话。电话那头的一名男子说他是唐娜的亲戚，并解释说家里有人生病了。因此，唐娜无法去上班。她的雇主记录了她的缺勤，并认为她很快就会回来。但唐娜也没有出现在她的下一个轮班中，也没有再进行任何联系。现在感到担心的雇主通知了警方。他们拜访了唐娜的公寓，发现她那辆1968年的敞篷车停在前面。公寓内一尘不染。唐娜的衣服和信用卡还在那里，对她银行账户的检查显示它没有被动过。
Officers reached out to Donna's family, who revealed something alarming. There had been no illness in the family and they had no idea who could have called the casino on Donna's behalf. Donna's unexplained absence now took a sinister turn. Given that she wasn't the type to simply leave without an explanation, police suspected foul play. Intensive searches were conducted throughout the Lake Tahoe area, but to no avail. A witness reported having seen Donna walking near her apartment with a blonde-haired man on September 7, but this was never verified. Detectives speculated that Donna's disappearance could be connected to the case of another young nurse, Judith Ann Hakari, who had been abducted and murdered six months earlier.
警官联系了唐娜的家人，他们透露了一些令人担忧的事情。家里没有人病倒，他们也不知道是谁可能代表唐娜给赌场打了电话。唐娜无法解释的失踪现在变得险恶起来。鉴于她不是那种不加解释就离开的人，警方怀疑有谋杀嫌疑。在太浩湖地区进行了深入搜查，但无济于事。一名目击者报告说，9月7日看到唐娜和一个金发男子在她的公寓附近行走，但这从未得到证实。侦探们推测，唐娜的失踪可能与另一位年轻护士朱迪思·安·哈卡里的案件有关，她六个月前被绑架并谋杀。
Judith's savagely beaten body had been found in a shallow grave near Tahoe National Forest, but with little to go on, any connection to Donna's disappearance was purely speculative. Meanwhile, in San Francisco, two months had gone by with no further contact from the Zodiac killer. Then, on Wednesday, October 7, a postcard arrived at the office of the chronicle claiming to be from the Zodiac. Typed on a filing card, a message on the back had been crafted from newspaper clippings. It read, Dear editor, you'll hate me, but I've got to tell you, the pace isn't any slower. P.S. There are reports city police pig cops are closing in on me. Fuck, I'm crackproof. What is the price tag now?
朱迪思被残忍殴打的尸体在太浩国家森林附近的一个浅坟中被发现，但由于线索很少，与唐娜失踪的任何联系纯属推测。与此同时，在旧金山，两个月过去了，没有收到“黄道十二宫”杀手的进一步联系。然后，在10月7日星期三，一张明信片抵达了《纪事报》办公室，声称来自“黄道十二宫”。在一张归档卡上打印，背面的信息是用剪报拼凑而成的。上面写着：“亲爱的编辑，你会恨我，但我必须告诉你，节奏并没有变慢。附言：有报道称城市警察猪警察正在逼近我。操，我是防破解的。现在的悬赏价格是多少？”
It also featured a crosshair symbol crafted from red paper. Given this card was significantly different from the Zodiac's previous correspondence, detectives were unsure if it was genuine or a hoax. Whoever had sent it had also increased the Zodiac's death toll, including a number 13 to allude to his number of victims. By this time, one year had passed since the last confirmed to Zodiac attack, the murder of cab driver Paul Stein. There had been no breakthroughs, and both the media and the public were losing interest in the case. It wasn't long before the Zodiac made contact again. On October 26, an envelope arrived at the Chronicle with the strange symbol drawn in the top left
它还以一个用红纸制作的十字准星符号为特色。鉴于这张卡片与“黄道十二宫”之前的通信有很大不同，侦探们不确定它是真实的还是恶作剧。寄出它的人还增加了“黄道十二宫”的死亡人数，包括一个数字13，以暗示他的受害者人数。到这时，距离最后一次确认的“黄道十二宫”袭击——出租车司机保罗·斯坦的谋杀案——已经过去了一年。没有任何突破，媒体和公众对该案件的兴趣正在减弱。没过多久，“黄道十二宫”又联系了。10月26日，一个信封抵达了《纪事报》，左上角画着奇怪的符号
corner. It was a letter Z underneath a sharp zigzagging line bordered by four dots. On the back of the envelope, written diagonally to form a cross, were the words, Sorry, no cipher. This letter was addressed to Paul Avery, the journalist who had covered the vast majority of the newspaper's Zodiac stories. Inside the envelope was a black and white Halloween card depicting a dancing skeleton. The front of the card read, From your secret pal, I can feel it in my bones, you wake to know my name, and so I'll clue you in. Inside the card, the message concluded with the words, But then, why spoil the game? Happy Halloween. The Zodiac had handwritten his own message that read, Boo, you are doomed. Peek-a-boo.
角落。那是一个字母Z，下面是一条被四个点包围的尖锐之字形线。在信封背面，斜着写成十字形的是这样的话：“抱歉，没有密码。”这封信是写给保罗·艾弗里的，他是报道了该报绝大多数“黄道十二宫”故事的记者。信封里是一张黑白万圣节卡片，描绘了一个跳舞的骷髅。卡片正面写着：“来自你的秘密伙伴，我能在骨子里感觉到，你醒着想知道我的名字，所以我给你一点线索。”在卡片内，信息以这样的话结束：“但话说回来，为什么要破坏游戏呢？万圣节快乐。”“黄道十二宫”手写了他自己的信息，写着：“嘘，你注定要倒霉了。躲猫猫。”
On the back of the card, written in all capitals to form a cross, were the words, Paradise and slaves. Paradise had been spelled incorrectly with the letter C instead of an S. Intercepting this cross were the words, By gun, By knife, and By rope. As this was the first time the Zodiac had targeted a particular individual in his correspondence, investigators couldn't help but wonder, Would Paul Avery be targeted next? Shaken but undeterred by the looming threat, Paul Avery embarked on a 430 mile trip to Southern California. After words spread that he'd received a card from the Zodiac killer, a reader had contacted him with a theory too compelling to ignore.
在卡片背面，用全大写字母写成十字形的是这样的话：“天堂和奴隶。”“天堂”拼写错误，用字母C代替了S。与这个十字交叉的是这样的话：“用枪，用刀，用绳子。”由于这是“黄道十二宫”在通信中第一次针对特定个人，调查人员不禁想问：保罗·艾弗里会是下一个目标吗？尽管受到迫在眉睫的威胁，保罗·艾弗里还是踏上了前往南加州的430英里旅程。在传出他收到“黄道十二宫”杀手卡片的消息后，一位读者联系了他，提出了一个不容忽视的理论。
They'd been following the Zodiac case closely and recognized some similarities to an unsolved murder that had occurred in the city of Riverside four years earlier. Was it possible this had been the early work of the Zodiac? Intrigued by the theory, Paul Avery flew to Riverside to examine the case file for himself. On October 30, 1966, 18 year old Sherry Joe Bates had been stabbed to death by an unidentified assailant after leaving her college library. A broken watch and heel print from a military shoe were found at the scene. Her killer later sent anonymous letters confessing to the crime and, like the Zodiac, his writing was peppered with spelling and grammatical errors. Paul Avery read through the typed confession letter that had arrived at the Riverside Daily
他们一直密切关注“黄道十二宫”案件，并发现与四年前发生在里弗赛德市的一起未破谋杀案有一些相似之处。这可能是“黄道十二宫”早期的作品吗？保罗·艾弗里对这个理论很感兴趣，于是飞往里弗赛德亲自查看案件卷宗。1966年10月30日，18岁的雪莉·乔·贝茨在离开大学图书馆后被一名身份不明的袭击者刺死。现场发现了一块破碎的手表和一只军用鞋的鞋跟印。她的杀手后来寄出匿名信承认了罪行，而且像“黄道十二宫”一样，他的写作中充斥着拼写和语法错误。保罗·艾弗里读了那封在雪莉·乔谋杀案后寄给《里弗赛德日报》的打印认罪信。
Enterprise newspaper following Sherry Joe's murder. It read in part, She was young and beautiful, but now she is battered and dead. She is not the first and she will not be the last. Beware, I am stalking your girls now. Paul then examined the handwritten letters that had been sent to Sherry Joe Bates' father, the Riverside Police Department, and the Riverside Daily Enterprise newspaper. All three read, Bates had to die, there will be more. When Paul reached the bottom of the letter, he felt a jolt of surprise. Two of the letters sent by Sherry Joe's killer were signed with a squiggle. It looked like the letter Z.
信中部分写道：“她年轻漂亮，但现在她伤痕累累，已经死了。她不是第一个，也不会是最后一个。小心，我现在正在跟踪你们的女孩。”保罗随后检查了寄给雪莉·乔·贝茨父亲、里弗赛德警察局和《里弗赛德日报》的手写信件。三封信都写着：“贝茨必须死，还会有更多。”当保罗读到信的末尾时，他感到一阵惊讶。雪莉·乔杀手寄出的两封信都签着一个潦草的符号。它看起来像字母Z。
It didn't escape Paul's attention that the city of Riverside was named for a body of water, just like the Zodiac's other murder sites. Sherry Joe's car had also been disabled before her attack, similar to the experience reported by Kathleen Johns. Perhaps the Zodiac had inadvertently left evidence at the Bates' crime scene that could be traced back to him and had never taken credit for the murder because he knew it would be his undoing. If the Zodiac was indeed responsible for Sherry Joe's death, it would provide some compelling new clues to his identity. Sherry Joe's killer had written in his confession that he'd made her pay for the brush-offs she had given him in the past. This indicated he may have been of similar
保罗注意到，里弗赛德市（Riverside）的名字源于水体，这与“十二宫杀手”的其他谋杀地点如出一辙。雪莉·乔（Sherry Joe）在遇袭前，她的车也曾被人动过手脚，这与凯瑟琳·琼斯（Kathleen Johns）的遭遇类似。也许“十二宫”在贝茨（Bates）的犯罪现场无意中留下了可以追溯到他的证据，但他从未承认过这起谋杀，因为他知道那将是他的末日。如果“十二宫”确实应对雪莉·乔的死负责，这将为他的身份提供一些令人信服的新线索。雪莉·乔的凶手在供词中写道，他让她为过去对他的冷落付出了代价。这表明他当时的年龄可能与雪莉·乔相仿，
age to Sherry Joe in 1966, meaning the Zodiac would now be in his early to mid-20s. Perhaps he'd previously lived in Riverside and made the move to San Francisco in recent years. Handwriting expert Sherwood Murill examined letters on the three notes sent to Sherry Joe's father, Riverside PD, and the local newspaper. He concluded there was a high probability that it matched the handwriting of the Zodiac killer. Following Sherry Joe's murder, a disturbing poem had been found scratched into a desk at her college library, which was believed to have been written by her killer. Murill analyzed this too and concluded, quote, it is unquestionably the work of the Zodiac. Police in Riverside weren't convinced. They'd recently been looking into
即1966年时，这意味着“十二宫”现在应该在20多岁到30岁出头。也许他以前住在里弗赛德，近年来搬到了旧金山。笔迹专家舍伍德·穆里尔（Sherwood Murill）检查了寄给雪莉·乔父亲、里弗赛德警察局和当地报纸的三封信件。他得出结论，这些笔迹与“十二宫”杀手的笔迹高度吻合。雪莉·乔遇害后，人们在她大学图书馆的课桌上发现了一首令人不安的诗，据信是凶手所写。穆里尔也对此进行了分析，并得出结论，引用如下：“这毫无疑问是‘十二宫’的作品。”但里弗赛德的警方并不信服。他们最近一直在调查
a local man who they considered a prime suspect in Sherry Joe's murder. However, the San Francisco Police Department and the FBI found the theory compelling, and an investigator was assigned to re-examine Sherry Joe's case full-time. On November 16, 1970, the Los Angeles Times published an article exploring the possible connections. Four months later, a letter arrived at the newspaper's offices. It read, in part, this is the Zodiac speaking. Like I have always said, I am crackproof. If the blue meanies are ever going to catch me, they had best get off their fat arses and do something. I do have to give them credit for stumbling across my Riverside activity, but they are only finding the easy ones. There are a hell of a lot more down there.
一名当地男子，他们认为该男子是雪莉·乔谋杀案的主要嫌疑人。然而，旧金山警察局和联邦调查局（FBI）认为这一理论很有说服力，并指派了一名调查员全职重新审查雪莉·乔的案件。1970年11月16日，《洛杉矶时报》发表了一篇文章，探讨了这些可能的联系。四个月后，报社收到了一封信。信中部分内容写道：“我是‘十二宫’。就像我一直说的那样，我是无法被破解的。如果那些‘蓝衣恶棍’（警察）真的想抓住我，他们最好从他们肥胖的屁股上站起来做点什么。我确实得承认，他们偶然发现了我在里弗赛德的活动，但他们找到的只是些简单的案子。在那儿还有一大堆呢。”
Riverside Police dismissed this final claim. They had no other unsolved homicides that could possibly fit with the Zodiac's crimes. Sierra Club, around in the snow, sought victim 12, peeked through the pines, past Lake Tahoe areas. These were the cryptic words that arrived on a postcard addressed to Paul Avery at the Chronicle one week later. The front featured an artist's impression of the new Forest Pines housing development in Lake Tahoe, Nevada, right on the border with California. The promotional image, which depicted a snowy neighborhood framed by pine trees, had been widely circulated in many Northern California newspapers the weekend prior. In the bottom right-hand corner, the Zodiac crosshair was scrawled in thick ink,
里弗赛德警方驳回了这一最终说法。他们没有其他未破的凶杀案能与“十二宫”的罪行相吻合。“塞拉俱乐部（Sierra Club），在雪地里徘徊，寻找第12名受害者，透过松树窥视，经过太浩湖地区。”这是一周后寄给《纪事报》保罗·艾弗里（Paul Avery）的一张明信片上写下的神秘文字。明信片正面是内华达州太浩湖新开发的“森林松树”（Forest Pines）住宅区的艺术效果图，就在加州边境。这张宣传图片描绘了一个被松树环绕的雪景社区，在之前的一个周末已在北加州的许多报纸上广泛流传。在右下角，用粗墨水潦草地画着“十二宫”的十字准星标志，
although the rest of the card was notably different to other Zodiac correspondences. When detectives saw the postcard, they guessed which case the message was referring to. It had now been six months since 25-year-old casino nurse Donna Lass disappeared without a trace from the South Lake Tahoe area. Nothing about her case fit the Zodiac's M.O., but investigators were intrigued enough to dig deeper. They looked into Donna's history and discovered that she shared a loose connection with one of the Zodiac's victims. At the time of Caby Paul Stein's murder, Donna was living just six blocks from where his body was found. She had also worked at a hospital in the Presidio, the park where the
尽管明信片的其余部分与“十二宫”的其他通信明显不同。当侦探们看到这张明信片时，他们猜到了这条信息指的是哪个案件。25岁的赌场护士唐娜·拉斯（Donna Lass）从南太浩湖地区失踪已过去六个月，至今杳无音讯。她的案件与“十二宫”的作案手法（M.O.）并不完全吻合，但调查人员对此产生了浓厚兴趣，决定深入挖掘。他们调查了唐娜的背景，发现她与“十二宫”的一名受害者有着微弱的联系。在出租车司机保罗·斯坦（Paul Stein）遇害时，唐娜住的地方距离发现他尸体的地方仅六个街区。她还曾在普雷西迪奥（Presidio）的一家医院工作，那里是
Zodiac was believed to have hidden after killing Paul. In the top right corner of the Zodiac's postcard, a single hole had been punched out to emit a section of land in the Forest Pines development. Believing that this could be where Donna Lass's body was buried, police waited until recent heavy snowfall had thawed before launching a thorough excavation of the site. However, they found nothing of significance. The Zodiac's attempt to draw attention to the area remained a mystery. Rumors began circulating that a detective may have sent the Lake Tahoe postcard in an attempt to further their career, or that a family member of Donna's had sent it out of desperation for her case to be solved. Torment Nagged at Donald Cheney
据信“十二宫”在杀害保罗后躲藏的公园。在“十二宫”明信片的右上角，有一个被戳出的圆孔，指向“森林松树”开发区的一块土地。警方认为这可能是唐娜·拉斯尸体的埋藏地，于是等到最近的大雪融化后，对该地点进行了彻底的挖掘。然而，他们没有发现任何有价值的东西。“十二宫”试图引起对该地区注意的行为仍然是一个谜。坊间开始流传谣言，称可能是一名侦探为了提升自己的职业生涯而寄出了这张太浩湖明信片，或者唐娜的家人因急于破案而寄出了它。折磨一直困扰着唐纳德·切尼（Donald Cheney）
For years, he'd been stewing over a disturbing conversation he'd had with a friend during a hunting trip in 1968. It had all started with the words, Have you ever thought of hunting people? Not only had the friend described in haunting detail the way he'd carry out a murder, but he'd even figured out exactly who his victims would be. It seemed as though his friend was thrilled not only by the notion of killing people, but the thought of toying with the detectives tasked with solving his crimes. Donald's friend had mentioned how he would send the police confusing letters, which he would sign off with the moniker, the Zodiac.
多年来，他一直对1968年一次狩猎旅行中与一位朋友进行的令人不安的谈话耿耿于怀。这一切都始于这样一句话：“你有没有想过猎杀人类？”这位朋友不仅以令人毛骨悚然的细节描述了他将如何实施谋杀，甚至还算计好了他的受害者会是谁。似乎他的朋友不仅对杀人的念头感到兴奋，还对戏弄那些负责破案的侦探感到兴奋。唐纳德的朋友提到，他会给警察寄去令人困惑的信件，并以“十二宫”这个绰号署名。
While the conversation itself had been enough to make Donald feel uneasy, it wasn't until the Zodiac killer began making headlines that he realized his friend might have been serious. When Donald read about the Zodiac's threats to shoot children as they came off the school bus, he remembered that his friend had made a similar comment. He'd said he would shoot the tires off the bus and then quote, pick off the little darlings as they bounced out. When Donald saw a sketch of the suspect, his heart skipped a beat. It looked remarkably similar to his friend. Donald couldn't keep this information to himself any longer. He confided in a work
虽然这次谈话本身就足以让唐纳德感到不安，但直到“十二宫”杀手开始登上头条，他才意识到他的朋友可能是认真的。当唐纳德读到关于“十二宫”威胁要在孩子们下校车时射杀他们的报道时，他想起他的朋友曾发表过类似的评论。他说他会射爆校车的轮胎，然后引用：“把那些蹦蹦跳跳的小宝贝们一个个点名干掉。”当唐纳德看到嫌疑人的素描时，他的心跳漏了一拍。那看起来和他的朋友惊人地相似。唐纳德再也无法将这些信息藏在心里了。他向一位工作
colleague who summoned the Los Angeles County police. Two detectives visited the man's workplace to take Donald's statement. After holding it in for years, he finally gave them the name of his friend. Arthur Lee Allen On August 4, 1971, lead detectives David Toskey and William Armstrong pulled up at the Penal Oil Refinery, 10 miles south of Vallejo. They were joined by Detective John Mullenax from the Vallejo Police Department. The trio approached Arthur Lee Allen's employer who'd been made aware of their impending visit. He'd took the officers to Allen, who had just started
同事吐露了实情，同事召集了洛杉矶县警方。两名侦探拜访了该男子的工作场所，记录了唐纳德的陈述。在隐瞒了多年之后，他终于说出了他朋友的名字：亚瑟·李·艾伦（Arthur Lee Allen）。1971年8月4日，首席侦探大卫·托斯基（David Toschi）和威廉·阿姆斯特朗（William Armstrong）驱车来到瓦列霍以南10英里的佩纳尔炼油厂（Penal Oil Refinery）。瓦列霍警察局的约翰·穆莱纳克斯（John Mullenax）侦探也加入了他们的行列。三人找到了亚瑟·李·艾伦的雇主，他已被告知警方即将到访。他带着警官们找到了艾伦，艾伦刚开始
working as a junior chemist. Allen looked confused as he realized the three detectives were there to interview him. When told that an anonymous source had linked him to the Zodiac attacks, Allen was taken aback. However, this wasn't the first time that he'd been questioned in relation to one of the Zodiac murders. Police had spoken to him after the attack against Cecilia Shepard and Brian Hartnell at Lake Berryessa. However, Allen said he couldn't even follow the Zodiac story in the news because he found it too morbid. For some unknown reason, a member of the public had tipped police off to Allen after the Lake Berryessa attack. He claimed he was nowhere near the lake on the day in question, but 100 miles away
工作，担任初级化学家。当艾伦意识到这三名侦探是来审问他时，他显得很困惑。当被告知有一个匿名消息来源将他与“十二宫”袭击事件联系起来时，艾伦大吃一惊。然而，这并不是他第一次因“十二宫”谋杀案而受到盘问。在塞西莉亚·谢泼德（Cecilia Shepard）和布莱恩·哈特内尔（Brian Hartnell）于伯耶萨湖（Lake Berryessa）遇袭后，警方曾找过他。然而，艾伦说他甚至无法在新闻中关注“十二宫”的故事，因为他觉得这太病态了。出于某种未知的原因，在伯耶萨湖袭击事件后，一名公众向警方举报了艾伦。他声称在事发当天他根本不在湖边，而是在100英里外
diving at Salt Point State Park. He returned to the home he shared with his mother in Vallejo at around 4pm and stayed there for the remainder of the evening. Police had asked if there was anyone who could verify this alibi. Allen said he'd met a couple at Salt Point but couldn't remember their names. He had also chatted with a neighbor after pulling into his driveway, but they had passed away one week later and couldn't confirm this interaction. Curiously, this was a detail he'd neglected to mention during his first police interview. 37-year-old Allen admitted to having an interest in firearms and said he owned some 22-colour by handguns. Before detectives could ask him about any other possible weapons, he suddenly
在盐点州立公园（Salt Point State Park）潜水。他在下午4点左右回到瓦列霍与母亲同住的家中，并在那里度过了余下的夜晚。警方询问是否有任何人可以证实这一不在场证明。艾伦说他在盐点遇到了一对夫妇，但不记得他们的名字了。他在驶入车道后还与一位邻居聊过天，但那个人一周后就去世了，无法证实这次互动。奇怪的是，这是他在第一次接受警方采访时忽略掉的细节。37岁的艾伦承认对枪支感兴趣，并说他拥有一些.22口径的手枪。在侦探们询问他是否有其他可能的武器之前，他突然
blurted out. The two knives I had in my car with blood on them, the blood came from a chicken I killed. The investigators were stunned. Perhaps Allen was under the impression that they had more information about him than they actually did. Later, again without being asked, Allen mentioned that he'd been in Southern California at the time of Sherry Joe Bates's murder. He denied having any incriminating conversations like the one Donald Cheney had described, but admitted that he'd read a short story named The Most Dangerous Game, which had left a lasting impression on him. The tale featured descriptions of a bored hunter who decided to start targeting humans instead of animals, and it had been speculatively
脱口而出：“我车里那两把带血的刀，血是来自我杀的一只鸡。”调查人员惊呆了。也许艾伦以为他们掌握的信息比实际掌握的要多。后来，在没有被问及的情况下，艾伦又提到他在雪莉·乔·贝茨（Sherry Joe Bates）谋杀案发生时身处南加州。他否认进行过唐纳德·切尼所描述的那种令人发指的谈话，但承认他读过一篇名为《最危险的游戏》（The Most Dangerous Game）的短篇小说，这给他留下了深刻的印象。故事描述了一个无聊的猎人决定开始以人类而不是动物为目标，这被推测为
linked to the first confirmed zodiac cipher. As detectives chatted with Allen, they happened to notice he was wearing a distinctive looking watch. He claimed it had been a gift from his mother two years earlier. Detective Toskey asked if they could take a closer look. Allen obliged and leaned his arm closer to the detectives. The face of the watch was imprinted with a crosshair symbol. Written across the watch was the brand name, Zodiac. Detective John Mullenax finished typing up his report of the interview with Allen, concluding with the line. After interviewing Allen, it is the opinion of all three investigators that further investigation should be conducted. Ted Kidder, who had previously employed Allen
与第一个被证实的“十二宫”密码有关。当侦探们与艾伦交谈时，他们碰巧注意到他戴着一块外观独特的手表。他声称这是他母亲两年前送的礼物。托斯基侦探询问他们是否可以仔细看看。艾伦顺从地将手臂靠近侦探。表盘上印着一个十字准星符号。手表上写着品牌名称：“Zodiac”（十二宫）。约翰·穆莱纳克斯侦探写完了关于艾伦的采访报告，并在结尾写道：“在采访了艾伦之后，三名调查人员一致认为应该进行进一步调查。”泰德·基德（Ted Kidder），曾雇佣艾伦
as a lifeguard and trampoline instructor, told the inspectors that Allen was fired after numerous people complained about his inappropriate behavior towards children. It was no surprise to Kidder that Allen was now considered a suspect in the zodiac killings. The thought of Allen's possible involvement had crossed his mind before, and he'd recently discussed the matter with another co-worker. As far as they were concerned, Allen was a sexual deviant, a loner, and a likely suspect. The other former co-worker, a man named Philip, was also pulled aside and questioned by investigators. He remembered discussing the zodiac case with Allen, who'd mentioned he was questioned about the Lake Berryessa attack. In another conversation, Allen told Philip about a great idea he had.
担任救生员和蹦床教练，告诉调查人员，艾伦在多人投诉他对待儿童的行为不当后被解雇了。基德对艾伦现在被视为“十二宫”谋杀案的嫌疑人并不感到惊讶。艾伦可能参与其中的想法以前就曾在他脑海中闪过，他最近还与另一位同事讨论过这件事。在他们看来，艾伦是一个性变态者、一个独行侠，也是一个可能的嫌疑人。另一位前同事，一个名叫菲利普（Philip）的人，也被调查人员拉到一边进行盘问。他记得曾与艾伦讨论过“十二宫”案件，艾伦提到他曾因伯耶萨湖袭击事件受到盘问。在另一次谈话中，艾伦告诉菲利普一个好主意。
If a person were to attach a special light to the barrel of their gun, they would be able to see their target in the dark of night and shoot them down. Notably, this is one of the tactics the zodiac claimed to have used when gunning down David Faraday and Betty Lou Janssen. Philip owned a brown Corvair, similar to the one driven by the perpetrator who would shot Darlene Farron and Michael Majo in Blue Lake Springs. Around the time of this attack, Philip was trying to sell his vehicle. He left it parked on display at a service station for two weeks, with the keys inside the station for anyone who might like to test drive it. One of the employees who worked there at that time was Arthur Lee Allen.
“如果一个人在枪管上安装一个特殊的灯，他们就能在黑夜中看到目标并将他们击毙。”值得注意的是，这是“十二宫”声称在枪杀大卫·法拉第（David Faraday）和贝蒂·卢·詹森（Betty Lou Janssen）时使用的策略之一。菲利普拥有一辆棕色的科维尔（Corvair），与在蓝湖泉（Blue Lake Springs）枪杀达琳·法林（Darlene Ferrin）和迈克尔·马乔（Michael Mageau）的凶手所驾驶的车辆相似。在那次袭击发生前后，菲利普正试图卖掉他的车。他把它停在一家服务站展示了两个星期，钥匙就放在站内，供任何想试驾的人使用。当时在那里工作的一名员工就是亚瑟·李·艾伦。
But that wasn't all. Philip and his wife had visited Allen at his mother's house when he suddenly announced he had something to show them. Allen went to his basement bedroom and produced a grey metal box. Inside was a piece of paper regarding a person who Allen claimed had been committed to a Tascadero State Hospital in San Luis Obispo County for sexually abusing a child. Riddled throughout the paragraphs were symbols. They were meticulously neat and resembled the zodiac ciphers to a tee. Philip's wife was fascinated by the symbols and asked if she could take the paper home to study it. But Allen refused and shoved it back into the box. Allen's sister-in-law, Karen, told detectives that Allen openly detested his mother, hated women,
但这还不是全部。菲利普和他的妻子曾拜访过艾伦在他母亲家的住处，当时他突然宣布他有东西要给他们看。艾伦走进他地下室的卧室，拿出一个灰色金属盒。里面有一张纸，关于一个艾伦声称因猥亵儿童而被关进圣路易斯奥比斯波县阿塔斯卡德罗州立医院（Atascadero State Hospital）的人。段落中到处都是符号。它们非常整洁，与“十二宫”的密码如出一辙。菲利普的妻子对这些符号很着迷，问她是否可以把纸带回家研究。但艾伦拒绝了，并把它塞回了盒子里。艾伦的嫂子凯伦（Karen）告诉侦探，艾伦公开厌恶他的母亲，憎恨女性，
and had never had a relationship with anyone his own age. Instead, he had a disturbing fixation with children. Karen admitted that Allen needed psychiatric help, but she did not believe he was the zodiac. However, when looking through the numerous letters sent by the zodiac over the years, one caught Karen's attention. On the Christmas letter sent to Melvin Belli, the zodiac had incorrectly spelled Merry Christmas with two S's. Karen had received a Christmas card from Allen in which he had misspelled Christmas the same way. Detectives followed up Allen's old employer at the service station who put one concern to rest. Allen had been fired months before Philip's brown corvair was left unattended at the station,
并且从未与任何同龄人建立过关系。相反，他对儿童有一种令人不安的执着。凯伦承认艾伦需要精神治疗，但她不相信他是“十二宫”。然而，在查看“十二宫”多年来寄出的众多信件时，有一封引起了凯伦的注意。在寄给梅尔文·贝利（Melvin Belli）的圣诞信中，“十二宫”错误地将“Merry Christmas”拼写成了带有两个“S”的“Christmass”。凯伦曾收到过艾伦寄来的一张圣诞贺卡，他在上面也以同样的方式拼错了“Christmas”。侦探们随后联系了艾伦在服务站的老雇主，他打消了一个顾虑。艾伦在菲利普的棕色科维尔被留在服务站无人看管的几个月前就被解雇了，
due to his habit of arriving at work intoxicated, missing shifts altogether, and being, quote, too interested in small girls. Allen hadn't always been an unreliable employee. When he worked at Valley Springs Elementary School in 1966, he had only ever taken one sick day. On November 1, the day after Sherry Joe Bates' body was discovered in Riverside. Despite the 400-mile distance between Valley Springs and Riverside, Allen had mentioned to detectives that he'd been in Southern California at the time of Sherry Joe's murder. Detectives searched a trailer that Arthur Lee Allen owned in Santa Rosa, 45 miles from his mother's house in Vallejo, but didn't find any concrete evidence linking him to
原因是他有上班酗酒、缺勤的习惯，而且，引用：“对小女孩太感兴趣了。”艾伦并不总是一个不可靠的员工。当他1966年在瓦利斯普林斯小学（Valley Springs Elementary School）工作时，他只请过一天病假。是在11月1日，也就是雪莉·乔·贝茨的尸体在里弗赛德被发现的第二天。尽管瓦利斯普林斯和里弗赛德之间有400英里的距离，但艾伦曾向侦探提到，他在雪莉·乔谋杀案发生时身处南加州。侦探们搜查了亚瑟·李·艾伦在圣罗莎（Santa Rosa）拥有的一辆拖车，距离他母亲在瓦列霍的家45英里，但没有发现任何确凿的证据将他与
any of the zodiac crimes. Regardless, he had started to emerge as the most promising suspect so far. A background check confirmed Allen had been in the Navy in the late 1950s, but was dishonorably discharged. He also wore a size 10.5 shoe, the same as the prints that had been found in the Lake Beriesa attack. The evening of Friday, April 7, 1972, almost two and a half years since the murder of Paul Stein in Tamil Pius Valley, California. It was just before 9 p.m. when 33-year-old legal secretary Isabel Watson strolled through the neighborhood where she lived. As Isabel made her way along Pine Hill Road, she suddenly felt a shocking blow.
任何“十二宫”罪行联系起来。无论如何，他已经开始成为迄今为止最有希望的嫌疑人。背景调查证实艾伦在20世纪50年代末曾在海军服役，但被不光彩地开除了。他还穿10.5码的鞋，这与在伯耶萨湖袭击事件中发现的脚印尺寸相同。1972年4月7日星期五晚上，距离保罗·斯坦在加州泰米尔帕斯谷（Presidio Heights）遇害已过去近两年半。晚上9点前不久，33岁的法律秘书伊莎贝尔·沃森（Isabel Watson）漫步在她居住的社区。当伊莎贝尔沿着松山路（Pine Hill Road）走时，她突然感到一阵剧烈的冲击。
A car had knocked her to the ground. The male driver leapt from the vehicle, a late model Ford or Chevrolet sedan. He looked to be in his early 40s and was about 5'9'' with the stocky build, brown hair and black-framed glasses. He apologized profusely to Isabel and offered to drive her home. Isabel was unharmed and felt fine to continue on alone, so she politely declined the offer. Her refusal enraged the man. He began to pummel her in the neck and up her back. Isabel screamed in pain, prompting her attacker to flee the scene. It was then that Isabel noticed the blood. The man hadn't been hitting her at all. He had been stabbing her repeatedly.
一辆车把她撞倒在地。男司机从车里跳出来，那是一辆后期款的福特或雪佛兰轿车。他看起来40岁出头，身高约5英尺9英寸，身材魁梧，棕色头发，戴着黑框眼镜。他向伊莎贝尔连连道歉，并提出开车送她回家。伊莎贝尔没有受伤，觉得可以独自继续前行，所以礼貌地拒绝了。她的拒绝激怒了那个男人。他开始猛击她的脖子和背部。伊莎贝尔尖叫着痛苦，促使袭击者逃离了现场。就在那时，伊莎贝尔注意到了血迹。那个男人根本不是在打她。他一直在反复刺伤她。
Isabel was taken to a hospital for treatment. When law enforcement officers learnt of the senseless attack, they couldn't help but notice the culprit's striking similarities to the Zodiac. Napa County Sheriff's Captain Ken Nalo was particularly intrigued. By this point, he'd been chasing the Zodiac for 2.5 years and Isabel Watson's attacker perfectly matched the description of the man he was hunting. Speaking to the media, Nalo said, I think it's a good chance it was him. You get a certain feeling about things. I got a feeling about this one. In September of 1972, Detective David Toskey arrived at the Sunset Trailer Park in Santa Rosa and made his way to the pink and white trailer owned by Arthur Lee Allen.
伊莎贝尔被送往医院接受治疗。当执法人员得知这起毫无意义的袭击时，他们不禁注意到罪犯与“十二宫”的惊人相似之处。纳帕县警长肯·纳洛（Ken Narlow）对此特别感兴趣。到目前为止，他已经追捕“十二宫”2.5年了，而伊莎贝尔·沃森的袭击者与他正在追捕的男子的描述完全吻合。在接受媒体采访时，纳洛说：“我认为很有可能是他。你对某些事情有一种直觉。我对这个案子有种预感。”1972年9月，大卫·托斯基侦探抵达圣罗莎的日落拖车公园（Sunset Trailer Park），径直走向亚瑟·李·艾伦拥有的粉白色拖车。
He knocked on the door, but there was no response. When Allen finally showed up, Toskey waved a search warrant in his face and made his way inside. There was a singular reason for Toskey's visit. He wanted a fresh handwriting sample. Even though Allen's handwriting had previously been compared to the Zodiac's and dismissed, rumours had been circulating that he was ambidextrous. According to one of Allen's relatives, he was naturally left-handed, but as a child, his teachers had forced him to write with his right hand. Knowing the previous sample had been written with his left hand, Toskey asked Allen to write
他敲了敲门，但没有人回应。当艾伦终于出现时，托斯基在他面前挥舞着搜查令，并进入了屋内。托斯基此行只有一个目的。他想要一份新的笔迹样本。尽管艾伦的笔迹之前曾与“十二宫”的笔迹进行过比对并被排除，但一直有传言称他是双撇子。据艾伦的一位亲戚说，他天生是左撇子，但小时候老师强迫他用右手写字。知道之前的样本是用左手写的，托斯基要求艾伦写
a sentence using his non-dominant hand instead. Allen picked up a pen with his right hand and began to write. After a few words, he complained it was too difficult. Toskey had to coax him to complete a small sample, with Allen insisting it was near impossible. Toskey wasn't convinced. It seemed as though Allen was trying too hard to pretend this was a challenging task. After investigators set their sights on Arthur Lee Allen, years passed with no further word or action from the Zodiac. Some speculated he had died or been incarcerated, or perhaps he was feeling the heat from the investigation. Life for Californians returned to normal as the killer faded from the headlines.
一句话，这次用他的非惯用手。艾伦用右手拿起笔开始写。写了几个字后，他抱怨说太难了。托斯基不得不劝说他完成一个小样本，而艾伦坚持说这几乎是不可能的。托斯基并不信服。艾伦似乎在极力假装这是一项艰巨的任务。在调查人员将目光锁定在亚瑟·李·艾伦身上后，几年过去了，“十二宫”再也没有任何消息或行动。有人推测他已经死亡或被监禁，或者也许他感受到了调查的压力。随着杀手从头条新闻中淡出，加州人的生活恢复了正常。
Then, three years later, on January 30, 1974, an envelope arrived at the San Francisco Chronicle. The printing of the line, please rush to editor, was unmistakable. The Zodiac suddenly and inexplicably resurfaced. Inside was a single piece of unlined paper on which was scrawled. I saw and think the Exorcist was the best satirical comedy that I have ever seen. Below that, the Zodiac had written, He plunged himself into the billowy wave and an echo arose from the Suicide's grave. This was yet another reference to a line performed by the Lord High Executioner in the
然后，三年后，1974年1月30日，一个信封寄到了《旧金山纪事报》。那行“请速交编辑”的打印字迹是无可辩驳的。十二宫突然且莫名其妙地重新浮出水面。里面是一张未划线的纸，上面潦草地写着：“我看了，并认为《驱魔人》（The Exorcist）是我看过的最好的讽刺喜剧。”在那下面，“十二宫”写道：“他投身于波涛汹涌的浪潮中，自杀者的坟墓里传来了回声。”这又是对《天皇》（The Mikado）中高级刽子手所表演台词的引用，
Mercado, the opera the Zodiac had alluded to in previous letters. This letter concluded with the words, P.S. If I do not see this note in your paper, I will do something nasty, which you know I'm capable of doing. A strange symbol followed, consisting of dots and thick lines. What it meant was anyone's guess. The letter finished with a final tally that read, The Chronicle granted his request by publishing the letter. After years of silence, news that the Zodiac had emerged once again captured the public's attention. Some readers wondered if the reference to suicide meant he planned to take his own life,
这是“十二宫”在之前的信件中提到过的歌剧。这封信以这样的话结尾：“附言：如果我没在你们的报纸上看到这篇笔记，我会做些令人讨厌的事，你们知道我有能力做到。”后面跟着一个奇怪的符号，由点和粗线组成。它的含义谁也猜不到。信件以一个最终的统计数字结尾，写着：“（杀人总数）”。《纪事报》满足了他的要求，发表了这封信。在沉默了多年之后，“十二宫”再次出现的消息引起了公众的关注。一些读者想知道，对自杀的引用是否意味着他计划结束自己的生命，
or stop killing once and for all. Investigators were just as uncertain as to how they should interpret this unexpected. Over the next few months, three similar letters followed. One was signed from a friend, another from a citizen, and the third was sent by someone in the city of San Rafael, who called themselves the Red Phantom. All of these shared similarities to the Zodiac's correspondence, but the handwriting differed slightly. To account for these differences, some theorized that the Zodiac might be ambidextrous, but investigators were unable to determine
或者彻底停止杀戮。调查人员同样不确定该如何解读这一突发事件。在接下来的几个月里，又收到了三封类似的信件。一封署名为“一个朋友”，另一封来自“一个公民”，第三封由圣拉斐尔市（San Rafael）的一个人寄出，他们自称为“红幻影”（Red Phantom）。所有这些信件都与“十二宫”的通信有相似之处，但笔迹略有不同。为了解释这些差异，一些人推测“十二宫”可能是双撇子，但调查人员无法确定
whether any were authentic or the work of a copycat. Detectives were still digging into the man many considered the prime Zodiac suspect, Arthur Lee Allen. In the mid-seventies, an investigator took Lake Berryessa survivor Brian Hartnell to a hardware store where Allen was working at the time. Brian browsed the shelves, pretending to be an ordinary customer, before taking an item to the till. While Allen rang up the purchase, Brian subtly observed him, taking in every physical feature. Brian hadn't seen the face of his attacker, as the man had been wearing a hood, but he noted that Allen's size, build, and voice was a match.
其中任何一封是真实的，还是模仿者的作品。侦探们仍在挖掘许多人认为的“十二宫”头号嫌疑人——亚瑟·李·艾伦。七十年代中期，一名调查员带着伯耶萨湖袭击事件的幸存者布莱恩·哈特内尔去了艾伦当时工作的五金店。布莱恩浏览了货架，假装成普通顾客，然后拿着一件商品去结账。当艾伦为商品结账时，布莱恩不动声色地观察着他，记下了每一个身体特征。布莱恩没有看到袭击者的脸，因为那个人戴着头套，但他注意到艾伦的身材、体格和声音都很吻合。
Investigators were intrigued by Brian's observations. On September 27, 1974, detectives arrived at Arthur Lee Allen's trailer in Santa Rosa, desperate to apprehend him. When their persistent knocking went unanswered, they picked the lock to get inside. Allen wasn't home, but incriminating evidence was seized. Then detectives headed to the lumberyard where Allen was now working, and arrested him on the spot. At the county jail, Allen sat with detectives without a lawyer present. He asked if he would be given a lighter sentence if he simply pleaded guilty. His arrest was the result of a statement provided by one of Allen's friends,
调查人员对布莱恩的观察很感兴趣。1974年9月27日，侦探们抵达亚瑟·李·艾伦在圣罗莎的拖车，急于逮捕他。当他们持续敲门无人应答时，他们撬开了锁进入屋内。艾伦不在家，但查获了确凿的证据。随后，侦探们前往艾伦现在工作的木材厂，当场逮捕了他。在县监狱，艾伦在没有律师在场的情况下与侦探坐在一起。他问如果他直接认罪，是否会得到较轻的判决。他的被捕是基于艾伦的一位朋友提供的陈述，
but she wasn't naming him as the Zodiac. This arrest was for an entirely different crime. Allen had sexually assaulted her eight-year-old son on multiple occasions. Investigators still didn't have any real evidence to pin the Zodiac crimes on Allen, despite survivor Brian Hartnell's statements. On March 14, 1975, after pleading guilty to the child molestation charges, Allen was sentenced to two and a half years at the Atascadero State Hospital, a mental health facility for individuals who had committed a criminal offense. Later that same year, a small group of ham radio enthusiasts in the Bay Area began
但她并没有指认他是“十二宫”。这次逮捕是因为一起完全不同的罪行。艾伦曾多次性侵她八岁的儿子。尽管有幸存者布莱恩·哈特内尔的陈述，调查人员仍然没有确凿的证据将“十二宫”罪行归咎于艾伦。1975年3月14日，在承认猥亵儿童罪名后，艾伦被判处在阿塔斯卡德罗州立医院服刑两年半，这是一个针对犯有刑事罪行个人的心理健康机构。同年晚些时候，湾区的一小群业余无线电爱好者开始
speaking to one another over the airwaves. One of the men, Richard Marshall, invited the others over to his basement apartment in San Rafael, a city approximately 18 miles north of San Francisco. Marshall was in his late 40s and was a film buff who worked as an operator in a silent theater. Although Marshall had made several comments over the radio that the others considered strange, they accepted his invitation. Upon entering his home, they were immediately struck by the troubling artwork on his walls. He had on display a large number of explicit images featuring young boys and possessed a large collection of pornographic literature.
在电波中互相交谈。其中一人，理查德·马歇尔（Richard Marshall），邀请其他人到他在圣拉斐尔的地下室公寓，这是一个距离旧金山约18英里的城市。马歇尔40多岁，是一个电影迷，在一家默片剧院担任放映员。尽管马歇尔在电台上发表了一些其他人认为很奇怪的评论，但他们还是接受了他的邀请。进入他家后，他们立即被墙上令人不安的艺术品所震撼。他展示了大量以小男孩为主角的露骨图片，并拥有大量色情文学收藏。
Throughout the evening, Marshall's behavior was extremely odd. At one stage, he remarked that he'd discovered something much more exciting than sex, but refused to elaborate. He also mentioned that he needed to lay low for a while, but didn't explain why. One of Marshall's visitors was Ted, not his real name. Ted had been following the Zodiac case closely over the years and began to wonder if Marshall could be the culprit. Ted thought Marshall bore an uncanny resemblance to the suspect sketches, right down to his thick-framed glasses. Furthermore, Marshall had lived in the Bay Area during all of the confirmed Zodiac attacks and was residing in Riverside at the time Sherry Joe
整个晚上，马歇尔的行为都极其古怪。有一次，他评论说他发现了一些比性更令人兴奋的事情，但拒绝详述。他还提到他需要低调一段时间，但没有解释原因。马歇尔的访客之一是泰德（Ted，化名）。泰德多年来一直密切关注“十二宫”案件，并开始怀疑马歇尔是否就是罪魁祸首。泰德认为马歇尔与嫌疑人素描有着惊人的相似之处，甚至连他那副粗框眼镜都一模一样。此外，马歇尔在所有已证实的“十二宫”袭击期间都住在湾区，并且在雪莉·乔·贝茨遇害时居住在里弗赛德。
Bates was murdered. Ted also found Marshall's remark about finding something better than sex was eerily reminiscent of the Zodiac's decoded cipher about killing being the greatest thrill, quote, better than getting your rocks off with a girl. Marshall invited his guests to watch one of his favorite films, El Espectro Rojo, which translates in English to the Red Phantom. This was of interest to Ted due to the possible Zodiac letter the Chronicle had received from someone using the same name. Moreover, that particular letter had been posted from San Rafael, the city where Marshall lived. On June 16, 1976, Ted sent a letter to the Napa County Sheriff's Department detailing his suspicions. Investigators were intrigued enough
泰德还发现马歇尔关于“发现比性更好的东西”的言论，令人毛骨悚然地让人想起“十二宫”解码密码中关于杀人是最大的快感，引用：“比和女孩做爱更爽。”马歇尔邀请他的客人们观看他最喜欢的电影之一《红幻影》（El Espectro Rojo），翻译成英文就是“The Red Phantom”。这对泰德来说很有趣，因为《纪事报》可能收到过某人用同样名字寄来的“十二宫”信件。而且，那封特定的信是从马歇尔居住的城市圣拉斐尔寄出的。1976年6月16日，泰德致信纳帕县警长办公室，详细说明了他的怀疑。调查人员对此很感兴趣，
to set up a meeting with Ted. When they showed him some of the confirmed Zodiac letters, even more similarities emerged. Ted recognized the oddly shaped pieces of paper used by the Zodiac as matching some he'd seen in Marshall's apartment. According to Ted, Marshall had a friend who worked in printing and supplied him with scrap paper. Ted also thought the Zodiac's handwriting looked similar to that of Marshall, who was ambidextrous. He often wrote with a black marker, which the Zodiac was sometimes known to do. Additionally, he owned a royal typewriter. The same model Sherry Joe Bates's killer was believed to have used when composing his confession letter. Marshall had served in the Navy and was skilled at drawing electric circuit diagrams,
并安排与泰德会面。当他们向他展示一些已证实的“十二宫”信件时，出现了更多的相似之处。泰德认出“十二宫”使用的形状奇特的纸张，与他在马歇尔公寓里看到的一些纸张相符。据泰德说，马歇尔有一个在印刷厂工作的朋友，为他提供了废纸。泰德还认为“十二宫”的笔迹看起来与马歇尔的相似，马歇尔是双撇子。他经常用黑色记号笔写字，而“十二宫”有时也会这样做。此外，他拥有一台皇家打字机。据信这是雪莉·乔·贝茨的凶手在撰写供词信时使用的同一型号。马歇尔曾在海军服役，擅长绘制电路图，
like the image of the bomb the Zodiac had drawn. He also spoke with the distinct draw, which fit the Zodiac's voice as described by survivor Brian Hartnell. Marshall was interviewed by detectives. They found him compelling, but ultimately concluded that he wasn't a strong suspect due to his fingerprints not matching any of those on file for the Zodiac. Marshall later spoke publicly about the case during a TV interview. He acknowledged that he and the Zodiac seemed to have a number of things in common, remarking, my innocence notwithstanding, the details do fit. By this point, detectives David Toskey and William Armstrong had been leading the Zodiac
就像“十二宫”画的炸弹图像一样。他说话时也带着独特的拖腔，这与幸存者布莱恩·哈特内尔描述的“十二宫”的声音相吻合。侦探们采访了马歇尔。他们觉得他很有嫌疑，但最终得出结论，由于他的指纹与档案中任何“十二宫”的指纹都不匹配，他不是一个强有力的嫌疑人。马歇尔后来在一次电视采访中公开谈论了这个案件。他承认他和“十二宫”似乎有很多共同点，并评论道：“尽管我是无辜的，但细节确实吻合。”此时，大卫·托斯基和威廉·阿姆斯特朗侦探已经领导“十二宫”
investigation for close to seven years. In September 1976, Armstrong requested to be reassigned elsewhere, while Toskey remained committed to the case. In an interview with the examiner, Toskey explained what drove him to pursue the case so doggedly, quote, I'll get to him one day and I'll bring him to justice. That's my motivation, justice. I'm not a vengeful type, but when a life is taken, there must be justice. Toskey acquired a celebrity status within San Francisco's police department, earning ongoing praise from the public and becoming the inspiration for police characters in the popular films Dirty Harry and Bullet. The public revered the hard-working inspector,
调查工作近七年了。1976年9月，阿姆斯特朗请求调往别处，而托斯基则继续致力于此案。在接受《审查者报》（Examiner）采访时，托斯基解释了是什么驱使他如此顽强地追查此案，引用：“总有一天我会抓住他，我会将他绳之以法。这就是我的动力，正义。我不是一个报复心强的人，但当生命被夺走时，必须有正义。”托斯基在旧金山警察局获得了名人地位，赢得了公众的持续赞誉，并成为流行电影《肮脏哈里》（Dirty Harry）和《警探哈里》（Bullitt）中警察角色的灵感来源。公众崇敬这位勤奋的警官，
with one girl writing him a letter that read, I imagine you see a lot of terrible, sad things, but I want you to know that in this crazy world of crooked people, you are a very special policeman. By late 1976, Detective Toskey had just seven years to go until he could retire from the police force. His mission was to solve the Zodiac case before then. As his seventh year on the case approached, he told the San Francisco examiner he was watching his mailbox to see if he received an anniversary card from the Zodiac. But the anniversary came and went without a word, and another year passed with no breakthroughs. By April of 1978, it had been more than four years since the last confirmed letter from the Zodiac had arrived, and some had started to wonder if
有一个女孩给他写了一封信，上面写着：“我想你一定见过很多可怕、悲伤的事情，但我希望你知道，在这个充满狡诈之人的疯狂世界里，你是一位非常特别的警察。”到1976年底，托斯基侦探距离从警队退休仅剩七年。他的使命是在那之前破获“十二宫”案件。随着他接手此案的第七年临近，他告诉《旧金山审查者报》，他一直在盯着自己的邮箱，看看是否会收到“十二宫”寄来的周年纪念卡。但周年纪念日过去了，却没有任何消息，又一年过去了，没有任何突破。到1978年4月，距离“十二宫”最后一封确认的信件寄出已经过去了四年多，有些人开始怀疑
perhaps the killer had died without ever being identified. All that changed on April 25 when an envelope appeared at the San Francisco Chronicle addressed to the editor. Inside was a short note written in familiar handwriting that concluded with the Zodiac's crosshair signature. It read, Dear editor, this is the Zodiac speaking. I am back with you. I have always been here. That city pig Toskey is good, but I am smarter and better. He will get tired, then leave me alone. I am waiting for a good movie about me. Who will play me? I am now in control of things. The return of the Zodiac excited Detective Toskey and nerves kicked in. He held a press conference, stating, I have always felt he was alive and out there,
也许凶手在没有被查明身份的情况下就已经死了。这一切在4月25日发生了变化，当时《旧金山纪事报》出现了一个寄给编辑的信封。里面是一张用熟悉的笔迹写的短条，结尾处有“十二宫”的十字准星签名。信上写着：“亲爱的编辑，我是‘十二宫’。我又回来了。我一直都在这里。那个城市猪托斯基很厉害，但我更聪明、更好。他会累的，然后就会离开我。我在等一部关于我的好电影。谁来演我？我现在掌控着一切。”“十二宫”的回归让托斯基侦探感到兴奋，同时也感到紧张。他举行了新闻发布会，声明：“我一直觉得他还活着，就在外面，
somewhere. I still don't know where he is, but at least now I know that all our work all these years definitely has not been in vain. When San Francisco Chronicle columnist Armistead Morpin read the latest Zodiac letter, he paused. There was something odd about it. The Zodiac had never singled out an individual police officer before, and now he'd mentioned Detective Toskey by name. This stood out to Armistead because of something he was keeping secret. Armistead had been writing a murder mystery series for the paper, and Toskey had been kind enough to provide him with valuable insights into homicide investigations to give his story a more authentic feel. Armistead was so inspired that he created a character
某个地方。我仍然不知道他在哪里，但至少现在我知道，我们这些年来所有的工作绝对没有白费。”当《旧金山纪事报》专栏作家阿米斯特德·莫平（Armistead Maupin）读到最新的“十二宫”信件时，他停顿了一下。信里有些奇怪。以前“十二宫”从未单独针对过某一位警官，而现在他提到了托斯基侦探的名字。这让阿米斯特德感到突出，因为他保守着一个秘密。阿米斯特德一直在为报纸撰写一系列谋杀悬疑小说，而托斯基曾好心地为他提供有关凶杀案调查的宝贵见解，使他的故事更具真实感。阿米斯特德深受启发，创造了一个角色
based on Toskey. His readers were so impressed that three of them wrote flattering letters of praise about Toskey and thanked Armistead for writing about him. However, there was something about the letters that Armistead couldn't ignore. All three had been typed on the same typewriter. He was certain that the letters had actually been written by Detective Toskey himself. Armistead felt so embarrassed for Toskey that he kept this belief to himself, that now he had a more troubling concern. Could Toskey have also written the latest Zodiac letter to bring the case back into the spotlight? Armistead reported his suspicions, and Toskey was confronted by his superiors. He admitted to sending the fan mail to Armistead,
以托斯基为原型。他的读者印象非常深刻，以至于其中三个人写了赞美托斯基的信，并感谢阿米斯特德写关于他的故事。然而，这些信件中有些东西是阿米斯特德无法忽视的。这三封信都是用同一台打字机打出来的。他确信这些信实际上是托斯基侦探自己写的。阿米斯特德为托斯基感到非常尴尬，以至于他把这个想法藏在心里，但现在他有了更令人不安的担忧。托斯基会不会也写了最新的“十二宫”信件，以便让这个案子重新回到聚光灯下？阿米斯特德报告了他的怀疑，托斯基受到了上级的质询。他承认给阿米斯特德寄了粉丝信，
but steadfastly denied having anything to do with the most recent Zodiac letter. An investigation confirmed he was telling the truth. Although they couldn't be certain, authorities were convinced the latest letter was genuinely written by the Zodiac killer. However, the damage to Toskey's reputation had been done. On July 10, 1978, Detective Toskey was officially removed from the Zodiac case and demoted. It was a mortifying fall from grace for the celebrity detective. Over the next few years, the case continued to lag. As the Zodiac murders were committed across four separate jurisdictions, there were multiple agencies involved. This had led to a messy and unwieldy investigation, which was further hindered by
但坚决否认与最近的“十二宫”信件有任何关系。调查证实他说的是实话。虽然他们无法确定，但当局确信最新的信件确实是“十二宫”杀手所写。然而，对托斯基声誉的损害已经造成。1978年7月10日，托斯基侦探被正式从“十二宫”案件中撤职并降职。对于这位名人侦探来说，这是一次令人羞辱的失宠。在接下来的几年里，案件继续停滞不前。由于“十二宫”谋杀案发生在四个不同的司法管辖区，涉及多个机构。这导致了一场混乱且笨拙的调查，并进一步受到
competitiveness, as each department strived to be the one that cracked the case. In 1981, California's Department of Justice was given all relevant files and asked to coordinate the investigation. One Vallejo detective publicly regretted that this hadn't happened sooner, stating if the Justice Department had controlled the case from the beginning, the Zodiac would be behind bars now. By December 1990, the investigation had entered its fourth decade. The Vallejo Police Department received word that an inmate in Santa Clara County Jail wanted to come clean with some information he'd been holding on to. He claimed to know the identity of the Zodiac killer and agreed to hand it over in exchange for a reduction of his sentence. Although skeptical, two Vallejo
竞争的阻碍，因为每个部门都争相成为破案的那一个。1981年，加州司法部获得了所有相关文件，并被要求协调调查。一位瓦列霍侦探公开表示遗憾，称如果司法部从一开始就控制此案，“十二宫”现在早就被关进监狱了。到1990年12月，调查已进入第四个十年。瓦列霍警察局收到消息，圣克拉拉县监狱的一名囚犯想要坦白他一直掌握的一些信息。他声称知道“十二宫”杀手的身份，并同意以减刑为交换条件将其交出。尽管持怀疑态度，两名瓦列霍
detectives traveled to Santa Clara to visit the man. He was 50-year-old career criminal, Robert Spinelli, who was facing charges for armed robbery. Spinelli agreed to divulge what he knew, but only if the charges against him were dropped. The detectives flat-out refused, asking Spinelli how he could be so certain he had the right person. Spinelli said that several days before taxi driver Paul Stein was murdered, a man he knew told him he was going to San Francisco to kill a cab driver. Spinelli refused to share the man's name, but was eventually convinced to do so by his lawyer. The man's name was Arthur Lee Allen. Investigators had never stopped considering Allen as a Zodiac suspect. This was despite the fact that his fingerprints did not match
侦探们前往圣克拉拉拜访了那名男子。他是一位50岁的职业罪犯，名叫罗伯特·斯皮内利（Robert Spinelli），当时正面临武装抢劫的指控。斯皮内利同意透露他所知道的情况，但前提是撤销对他的指控。侦探们断然拒绝，并询问斯皮内利为何如此确定他找对了人。斯皮内利说，在出租车司机保罗·斯坦（Paul Stein）被谋杀的前几天，他认识的一个人告诉他，他要去旧金山杀一名出租车司机。斯皮内利拒绝透露那个人的名字，但在律师的劝说下最终还是说了出来。那个人的名字是亚瑟·李·艾伦（Arthur Lee Allen）。调查人员从未停止将艾伦视为“十二宫杀手”的嫌疑人。尽管他的指纹与记录在案的任何可能的“十二宫”指纹都不匹配，而且艾伦也从未像“十二宫”那样被发现佩戴过黑框眼镜。
any of the possible Zodiac prints on record, and Allen had never been known to wear black-framed glasses like the Zodiac did. In 1977, Allen was released from a Tascadero state hospital after serving a two-year sentence for child molestation charges. Now, with the statement from Robert Spinelli, he'd been named in the Zodiac case again more than a decade later. Detectives weren't sure whether Spinelli was telling the truth or just had a former score to settle with Allen, but there were certain factors that sparked their interest. Firstly, Allen had never been publicly named as a suspect in the case. And secondly, during the period Allen was incarcerated, the Zodiac hadn't sent any new letters.
1977年，艾伦在阿塔斯卡德罗（Atascadero）州立医院服刑两年后获释，他当时因猥亵儿童罪入狱。现在，随着罗伯特·斯皮内利的证词，十多年后，他再次被列入“十二宫”案件的嫌疑人名单。侦探们不确定斯皮内利说的是实话，还是只是想和艾伦算旧账，但有一些因素引起了他们的兴趣。首先，艾伦此前从未被公开列为该案的嫌疑人。其次，在艾伦被监禁期间，“十二宫”没有寄出任何新的信件。
It was only in the months following his release that the chronicle received the final letter that began, I'm back. On February 14, 1991, police executed a search warrant at Allen's home in Vallejo and found a number of suspicious items. There were several mail order catalogues featuring guns and booby traps and an older royal typewriter with a late type. This was believed to be the same model typewriter that Sherry Joe Bates's killer had used to compose his confession. Handwritten formulas and supplies for bomb making were also discovered. And in the property's basement, police found several completed pipe bombs. This startled them, as one of the Zodiac's letters had mentioned storing a bomb in his basement. Police also found a letter from
直到他获释后的几个月里，《纪事报》才收到了那封以“我回来了”开头的最后一封信。1991年2月14日，警方对艾伦位于瓦列霍（Vallejo）的住所执行了搜查令，并发现了许多可疑物品。其中包括几本邮购目录，里面有枪支和诱杀装置，还有一台旧的皇家打字机，字体较晚。据信，这与雪莉·乔·贝茨（Sherry Joe Bates）的凶手用来撰写自白书的打字机是同一型号。警方还发现了手写的炸弹制造公式和材料。在房产的地下室里，警方发现了几个制作完成的管状炸弹。这让他们感到震惊，因为“十二宫”的一封信中曾提到在地下室存放炸弹。警方还发现了一封来自
investigator James Silver of the Department of Justice, which stated that Allen had passed a polygraph examination and should no longer be considered a suspect in the Zodiac case. Police thought this was odd and questioned Allen about it. He admitted he'd printed the letter during his time working in the Atascadero Hospital print shop, but maintained that it was authentic. James Silver denied this, saying he would never write such a letter. Nothing was found that tied Allen to any of the Zodiac victims, but police confiscated this letter and his Zodiac branded watch as evidence. Allen was furious. He decided it was finally time to break his silence. In July 1991, Allen gave his side of the story to news reporters, insisting he had
司法部调查员詹姆斯·西尔弗（James Silver）的信，信中称艾伦已通过测谎仪检查，不应再被视为“十二宫”案件的嫌疑人。警方认为这很奇怪，并就此询问了艾伦。他承认这封信是他自己在阿塔斯卡德罗医院印刷车间工作时印制的，但他坚称信的内容是真实的。詹姆斯·西尔弗否认了这一点，称他绝不会写这样的信。警方没有发现任何将艾伦与“十二宫”受害者联系起来的证据，但没收了这封信和他那块印有“十二宫”标志的手表作为证据。艾伦非常愤怒。他决定是时候打破沉默了。1991年7月，艾伦向新闻记者讲述了他的故事，坚称他已经
passed polygraph tests that confirmed he was not the Zodiac. He'd told the San Francisco Examiner, this damned thing has been haunting me for 22 years. No way in hell could I go out and kill innocent teeny bobbers. No way. But with the police, I'm guilty until I'm proven innocent, and I figure the case will be around until I die. Retired Vallejo Detective George Bowert was one of the investigators convinced that Allen was the Zodiac and persisted in his hunt for evidence. Bowert tracked down Zodiac survivor Michael Majo and took him a photo lineup of possible suspects. Michael scanned his eyes over the images looking for familiar features. He singled out a photo of an overweight, balding man and said,
通过了测谎测试，证实他不是“十二宫”。他告诉《旧金山考察家报》：“这该死的事情已经困扰我22年了。我绝不可能出去杀害无辜的年轻女孩。绝不可能。但在警察眼里，我被证明清白之前就是有罪的，我想这个案子会一直缠着我直到我死。”已退休的瓦列霍侦探乔治·鲍尔特（George Bowert）是坚信艾伦就是“十二宫”的调查人员之一，并坚持寻找证据。鲍尔特找到了“十二宫”的幸存者迈克尔·马乔（Michael Majo），并带给他一份嫌疑人照片排查表。迈克尔扫视着这些照片，寻找熟悉的特征。他挑出了一张超重、秃顶男人的照片，说道：
That's him. That's the man who shot me. It was Arthur Lee Allen. Investigators continued to focus on Allen, prompting a review into all previous correspondence from the Zodiac. The first cipher sent to the San Francisco Chronicle in 1969, dubbed the 408 Cipher, ended with a final line that had never been officially decoded. At the time, one citizen who was interested in the case said he'd found a solution that translated into the words Robert Emmett the hippie. Investigators had searched for a Robert Emmett with no success. In August of 1992, detectives made a breakthrough. They discovered that Allen had gone to high school with a boy named Robert Emmett Rodifer. Robert had gone on to study at the University
“就是他。就是那个开枪打我的人。”那人正是亚瑟·李·艾伦。调查人员继续将重点放在艾伦身上，促使他们重新审查了“十二宫”之前的所有通信。1969年寄给《旧金山纪事报》的第一份密码，被称为“408密码”，最后一行从未被正式破译。当时，一位对该案感兴趣的市民说，他找到了一个解决方案，翻译过来是“嬉皮士罗伯特·埃米特”（Robert Emmett the hippie）。调查人员曾寻找过名为罗伯特·埃米特的男子，但没有成功。1992年8月，侦探们取得了突破。他们发现艾伦高中时曾与一个叫罗伯特·埃米特·罗迪弗（Robert Emmett Rodifer）的男孩是同学。罗伯特后来进入大学学习
of California Berkeley, during which time he became a hippie. He and Allen had never gotten along. Investigators managed to track Robert down in Germany. He confirmed that he knew Allen as a teenager, and suspected that Allen held a grudge against him out of jealousy. Over the years, detectives had amassed a case file of circumstantial evidence pointing to Allen as the prime suspect of the Zodiac killings. On August 26, 1992, they received some unexpected news. 58-year-old Allen had passed away. Initial speculation was that he had taken his own life, unable to cope with being labeled the Zodiac anymore. Though authorities were disappointed that their suspect had died before any charges
加州大学伯克利分校，期间他成了一名嬉皮士。他和艾伦一直合不来。调查人员设法在德国找到了罗伯特。他证实他青少年时期认识艾伦，并怀疑艾伦因嫉妒而对他怀恨在心。多年来，侦探们积累了一份间接证据档案，将艾伦指向为“十二宫”杀人案的主要嫌疑人。1992年8月26日，他们收到了一个意想不到的消息。58岁的艾伦去世了。最初的猜测是他自杀了，因为无法再承受被贴上“十二宫”标签的压力。尽管当局对嫌疑人在被起诉前就去世感到失望，但艾伦的死确实提供了一个机会。
could be laid, Allen's death did present one opportunity. It meant they could search his Vallejo home again. The next morning, detectives descended on Allen's modest Spanish mission-style house. Inside, they found strips of paper containing mathematical calculations and another set of instructions for bomb building. However, it was during a search of a bookcase that detectives discovered what they were searching for. Crammed in amongst the books was a VHS tape. Written on the tape was a single letter, Z. Detectives inserted the tape into a VCR and pressed play. Allen appeared on screen, holding his pet dog. As the tape progressed, Allen began ranting about
这意味着他们可以再次搜查他在瓦列霍的家。第二天早上，侦探们突袭了艾伦那栋朴素的西班牙传教风格的房子。在里面，他们发现了写有数学计算公式的纸条和另一套炸弹制造说明。然而，正是在搜查书架时，侦探们发现了他们一直在寻找的东西。在书堆中塞着一盘VHS录像带。录像带上写着一个字母：Z。侦探们将录像带插入录像机并按下播放键。屏幕上出现了艾伦，怀里抱着他的宠物狗。随着录像带的播放，艾伦开始咆哮着
the Vallejo police department. Any hope that Allen would confess to being the Zodiac killer dissipated, when instead of confessing, Allen pulled down his pants and mooned the camera. Dejected, Captain Ron Conway fronted the media but refused to discuss the search or the findings. He did put one room at a rest. Allen had not taken his own life. An autopsy confirmed he died of natural causes. Still, the captain was steadfast in his resolve that detectives would not give up, stating, It is still an ongoing criminal investigation. Allen's death has not changed that. In late 2000, an important package arrived at the San Francisco Police DNA crime lab. Inside the parcel were several stamped envelopes. Scientists assigned to the case
关于瓦列霍警察局的事。艾伦会承认自己是“十二宫”杀手的希望破灭了，因为他没有认罪，而是脱下裤子对着镜头露出了屁股。沮丧的罗恩·康威（Ron Conway）队长面对媒体，但拒绝讨论搜查过程或发现。他确实平息了一个传言：艾伦并非自杀。尸检证实他是自然死亡。尽管如此，队长仍坚定地表示侦探们不会放弃，并声明：“这仍然是一项正在进行的刑事调查。艾伦的死并没有改变这一点。”2000年末，一个重要的包裹送达了旧金山警察局的DNA犯罪实验室。包裹里有几封贴了邮票的信封。负责此案的科学家们
carefully removed the stamps from the envelopes, which all read, Please rush to editor. Improvements in DNA testing meant it was now possible that the saliva used to affix the stamps to the Zodiac envelopes could undoubtedly prove whether Arthur Lee Allen was the killer. The first step was to establish whether a DNA profile could be made from the stamps in the first place. Scientists were in luck. A partial profile was extracted from one of the stamps. A DNA profile for Allen was also extracted from brain tissue taken during his autopsy. It was a long and painstaking process held up by other active investigations which required urgent results. Two years later, the results were finally made public. Allen's genetic
小心翼翼地取下了信封上的邮票，上面都写着“请速寄给编辑”。DNA检测技术的进步意味着，现在有可能通过用于粘贴邮票的唾液，毫无疑问地证明亚瑟·李·艾伦是否就是凶手。第一步是确定是否能从邮票中提取出DNA图谱。科学家们很幸运。从其中一枚邮票中提取出了部分图谱。艾伦的DNA图谱也从他尸检时提取的脑组织中提取出来。这是一个漫长而艰苦的过程，由于其他需要紧急结果的调查而受到阻碍。两年后，结果终于公布。艾伦的基因
profile was not a match to the Zodiac stamp. By early 2004, the San Francisco Police Department had been investigating the Zodiac case for nearly 35 years. It had become one of the longest-running and most frustrating unsolved cases in the city's history. On April 8, 2004, the department announced that due to their overwhelming caseload, the Zodiac file was being declared inactive. Although they had more DNA on file that was yet to be tested, the crime lab was overloaded and more recent cases were given priority. All evidence relating to the Zodiac was locked away in a filing cabinet in the homicide office, with no intention of it being unlocked anytime soon.
图谱与“十二宫”邮票上的DNA不匹配。到2004年初，旧金山警察局调查“十二宫”案件已近35年。它已成为该市历史上持续时间最长、最令人沮丧的悬案之一。2004年4月8日，该部门宣布，由于案件积压严重，“十二宫”档案被宣布为非活跃状态。尽管他们档案中还有更多尚未检测的DNA，但犯罪实验室已不堪重负，较新的案件被优先处理。所有与“十二宫”相关的证据都被锁在凶杀案办公室的文件柜里，短期内没有解锁的打算。
Detectives in Napa Valley and Valejo kept their Zodiac files open, but for the first time since taxi driver Paul Stein was murdered, there would be no one in San Francisco actively investigating the serial killings. Three years later, it was reopened after the release of director David Fincher's film Zodiac sparked renewed interest in the case. The movie was based on a book by Robert Graysmith, a political cartoonist who'd worked for the San Francisco Chronicle during the period that the Zodiac sent letters to the newspaper. He'd become fascinated by the case and spent more than a decade trying to solve it. Graysmith was so convinced that Arthur Lee Allen was the Zodiac that he came under fire for twisting facts in order to make Allen look more suspicious.
纳帕谷（Napa Valley）和瓦列霍的侦探们保留了他们的“十二宫”档案，但自出租车司机保罗·斯坦被谋杀以来，旧金山首次没有人积极调查这些连环谋杀案。三年后，在大卫·芬奇（David Fincher）导演的电影《十二宫》上映并引发对该案的重新关注后，案件被重新开启。这部电影改编自罗伯特·格雷史密斯（Robert Graysmith）的书，他是一位政治漫画家，在“十二宫”向报社寄信期间曾在《旧金山纪事报》工作。他被这个案子深深吸引，花了十多年时间试图破案。格雷史密斯非常确信亚瑟·李·艾伦就是“十二宫”，以至于他因扭曲事实使艾伦看起来更可疑而受到抨击。
He withheld Allen's name in the book, instead naming him Bob Hall Star. Detective David Toskey was portrayed by actor Mark Ruffalo, who prepared for the role by spending time with the aging former detective. Like Robert Graysmith, Toskey remained convinced that Arthur Lee Allen was the killer, despite his DNA not matching the profile taken from the Zodiac stamp. On January 6th 2018, Toskey passed away from pneumonia in his San Francisco home. Graysmith penned his obituary for the New York Times, in which he noted, Dave Toskey cared about the victims far more than catching the Zodiac. And in this, he never failed. On March 3, 2007, almost 38 years after the first letter from the Zodiac killer arrived at the San
他在书中隐去了艾伦的名字，将其命名为“鲍勃·霍尔·斯塔”（Bob Hall Star）。侦探大卫·托斯基（David Toskey）由演员马克·鲁法洛（Mark Ruffalo）饰演，他通过与这位年迈的前侦探共度时光来为角色做准备。像罗伯特·格雷史密斯一样，托斯基仍然确信亚瑟·李·艾伦就是凶手，尽管他的DNA与从“十二宫”邮票上提取的图谱不匹配。2018年1月6日，托斯基在旧金山的家中因肺炎去世。格雷史密斯为《纽约时报》撰写了他的讣告，其中提到：“戴夫·托斯基关心受害者远胜于抓住‘十二宫’。在这一点上，他从未失败过。”2007年3月3日，距离“十二宫”杀手寄出的第一封信到达旧金山
Francisco Chronicle, editorial assistant Daniel King was sorting through old photo files. As he flicked through them, a bright red envelope caught his eye. It was addressed to the editor in a familiar print. The envelope was postmarked from Eureka, California and dated December 1990. It's seal was still intact, meaning it had sat unopened for 16 years. Inside was a Christmas card, depicting a cartoon snowman wearing a Groucho Marks-inspired mask and a pre-printed message that read, From your secret pal, can't guess who I am yet. Well, look inside and you'll find out. That I'm gonna keep you guessing.
《纪事报》近38年后，编辑助理丹尼尔·金（Daniel King）正在整理旧照片档案。当他翻阅时，一个鲜红色的信封引起了他的注意。信封上写着给编辑的信，字体很熟悉。信封的邮戳来自加利福尼亚州尤里卡（Eureka），日期是1990年12月。它的封口完好无损，意味着它已经未被拆封地存放了16年。里面是一张圣诞贺卡，上面画着一个戴着格劳乔·马克思（Groucho Marx）风格面具的卡通雪人，并印有一条预先打印的信息：“来自你的秘密伙伴，还没猜出我是谁吗？好吧，看看里面你就知道了。我会让你继续猜下去的。”
Happy holidays, anyway. The card wasn't signed and there was no personalized message, but a slip of folded paper was enclosed within. It contained a black and white photocopy of two United States Postal Service keys on a metal keychain. There was no explanation accompanying the image. Document examiners studied the writing on the envelope and debated whether it was an authentic Zodiac correspondence or a hoax. Researcher Tom Boyd, who operates the website ZodiacKiller.com, eventually traced the
“无论如何，节日快乐。”贺卡没有签名，也没有个性化留言，但里面夹着一张折叠的纸条。上面有一张黑白复印件，显示金属钥匙扣上的两把美国邮政服务钥匙。图片没有附带任何解释。文件鉴定专家研究了信封上的字迹，并争论这到底是真实的“十二宫”通信还是恶作剧。研究员汤姆·博伊德（Tom Boyd），即网站ZodiacKiller.com的运营者，最终追踪到了
identification numbers on the keys to a man who owned a post office box in Eureka. The man was looked into by police, but ruled out of the Zodiac investigation. The significance of the keys remains unknown. Over the decades, the mystery of the Zodiac Killer has created as much speculation amongst armchair detectives as it has for the case investigators. Amateur sleuths have formed their own task forces and met at the crime scenes to discuss their theories. Websites and online forums dedicated to dissecting every detail of the case have many devoted followers. Meanwhile, law enforcement agencies haven't given up hope that
钥匙上的识别号码，指向了一名在尤里卡拥有邮政信箱的男子。警方调查了该男子，但将其排除在“十二宫”调查之外。这些钥匙的意义仍然未知。几十年来，“十二宫”杀手的谜团在业余侦探和案件调查人员中引发了同样的猜测。业余侦探们组建了自己的特别工作组，并在犯罪现场会面讨论他们的理论。致力于剖析案件每一个细节的网站和在线论坛拥有许多忠实的追随者。与此同时，执法机构并没有放弃希望，即
the killer will one day be identified. Although Arthur Lee Allen's DNA ruled him out as a suspect, in 2018 a startling new revelation came to light. The DNA sample tested against Allen's had actually been obtained from the outside of one of the Zodiac's stamps. This meant the sample could have come from any number of individuals who had handled the mail in addition to the real Zodiac Killer. Even if Allen was responsible for the Zodiac letters, it's possible that he didn't lick the stamps himself. Several of Allen's acquaintances have since reported that he often asked them to lick stamps for him, as he couldn't stand the taste. One of these was his former friend Donald Cheney, who was responsible for naming Allen as a suspect.
凶手终有一天会被查明。尽管亚瑟·李·艾伦的DNA将他排除在嫌疑人之外，但在2018年，一个惊人的新发现浮出水面。与艾伦进行比对的DNA样本实际上是从“十二宫”邮票的外部获取的。这意味着样本可能来自除真正的“十二宫”杀手之外的任何处理过邮件的人。即使艾伦确实是“十二宫”信件的作者，他也有可能没有亲自舔邮票。艾伦的几位熟人后来报告说，他经常请他们帮他舔邮票，因为他受不了那个味道。其中一人就是他的前朋友唐纳德·切尼（Donald Cheney），他正是最初将艾伦列为嫌疑人的人。
In response to these allegations, Donald's DNA was tested against the sample taken from the Zodiac stamp. It wasn't a match either. To this day, a range of individuals have been accused of being the Zodiac, with varying levels of evidence and acceptance. Infamous murderers have been considered, including Killer Colt the Manson family, the Unabomber Ted Kozinski and the BTK serial killer Dennis Rader. Other suspects have had connections to confirmed or assumed victims, including a Riverside City College library assistant, a staff member at the casino where Donna Lass worked, a British automobile importer, and someone who went to the same schools as David Faraday and Betty Lou Jensen. A repeat offender named Lawrence Kane was scrutinized for his
针对这些指控，唐纳德的DNA与从“十二宫”邮票上提取的样本进行了比对。结果也不匹配。时至今日，一系列个人被指控为“十二宫”，证据和认可程度各不相同。臭名昭著的杀手也被考虑在内，包括“杀手科尔特”（Killer Colt）、曼森家族（Manson family）、“大学炸弹客”泰德·卡辛斯基（Ted Kaczynski）和BTK连环杀手丹尼斯·雷德（Dennis Rader）。其他嫌疑人与已确认或推测的受害者有联系，包括河滨城市学院的一名图书馆助理、唐娜·拉斯（Donna Lass）工作的赌场的一名员工、一名英国汽车进口商，以及一名与大卫·法拉第（David Faraday）和贝蒂·卢·詹森（Betty Lou Jensen）上同一所学校的人。一名叫劳伦斯·凯恩（Lawrence Kane）的累犯因其
possible ties to both confirmed and unconfirmed Zodiac victims. Darlene Farron's sisters claimed Kane was the man who had lurked in a white car outside Darlene's home after she claimed to have seen him kill someone. Kane also moved to South Lake Tahoe one month after Donna Lass and worked very close by to her. A popular suspect amongst internet sleuths today is Richard Gajkowski. A former US Army medic, Gajkowski had several circumstantial ties to Zodiac victims and crime scenes and occasionally went by the nickname Gajk, a word that can be seen clearly at the center of the Zodiac's 408 cipher, though the spelling is slightly off. Ultimately, no concrete evidence has ever been found to
与已确认和未确认的“十二宫”受害者之间可能的联系而受到审查。达琳·法伦（Darlene Ferrin）的姐妹们声称，凯恩就是那个在达琳声称看到他杀人后，潜伏在她家外白色汽车里的人。凯恩在唐娜·拉斯失踪一个月后也搬到了南太浩湖（South Lake Tahoe），并且工作地点离她非常近。今天在互联网侦探中很受欢迎的一名嫌疑人是理查德·盖科夫斯基（Richard Gaikowski）。作为一名前美国陆军医务兵，盖科夫斯基与“十二宫”受害者和犯罪现场有几处间接联系，偶尔使用绰号“Gajk”，这个词在“十二宫”的408密码中心清晰可见，尽管拼写略有偏差。最终，从未发现任何确凿证据来
incriminate either of these men. One person made a deathbed confession to being the Zodiac. Another did the same, but to an attorney, ensuring attorney-client privilege would secure his secret until he passed away. A merchant mariner, a newspaper editor, and an identity thief have also been considered as the Zodiac. Various people have come forward to accuse their friends and even family members of being the Zodiac. Despite years of ongoing investigations, the suspect list is as long as ever. Given the Zodiac was only ever known in broad strokes, many people could have fit the bill. Then there is the Zodiac hoax theory, in which some believe the killer never existed. Those who actually saw or spoke to the killer have identified
给这些人定罪。有人在临终前承认自己是“十二宫”。另一个人也做了同样的忏悔，但对象是律师，确保律师与客户的特权能保守他的秘密直到他去世。一名商船海员、一名报纸编辑和一名身份窃贼也被认为是“十二宫”。各种各样的人站出来指控他们的朋友甚至家人是“十二宫”。尽管经过多年的持续调查，嫌疑人名单依然很长。鉴于“十二宫”的特征一直只被模糊地了解，许多人都可能符合条件。然后是“十二宫”恶作剧理论，有些人认为凶手根本不存在。那些真正见过或与凶手交谈过的人，指认了
different people as being responsible. In 2021, an independent team of 40 former law enforcement investigators, military intelligence officers, and journalists named the casebreakers claimed they had identified the Zodiac killer as a deceased U.S. Air Force veteran named Gary Francis Post. This conclusion, like all the others, is based on circumstantial evidence and has not yet been proven. Complicating matters are the litany of pranksters and hoaxes that donned the Zodiac identity throughout the years. There is a distinct difference between the Zodiac who seems to encompass these types and more, and the actual Zodiac killer, the individual responsible for the crimes. As the lines have been blurred between these two identities over the years, it can be
不同的人是罪魁祸首。2021年，一个由40名前执法调查员、军事情报官员和记者组成的独立团队（自称“破案者”）声称，他们已确认“十二宫”杀手是一名已故的美国空军退伍军人，名叫加里·弗朗西斯·波斯特（Gary Francis Poste）。这一结论与所有其他结论一样，基于间接证据，尚未得到证实。使问题复杂化的是多年来冒充“十二宫”身份的众多恶作剧者。似乎涵盖了这些类型及更多内容的“十二宫”与实际的“十二宫”杀手（即对犯罪负责的个人）之间存在明显区别。随着多年来这两个身份之间的界限变得模糊，
impossible to determine what correspondence or incidents is attributed to either. In 1967, the father of stabbing victim Sherry Joe Bates, Riverside Police and the Press Enterprise editorial officers, received anonymous handwritten letters warning of more victims to come. All three letters were signed with a symbol that resembled the letter Z. For years, it was hotly speculated and at some points firmly believed that these letters were penned by the Zodiac long before he adopted the title. These letters led to the belief that Sherry Joe was the first Zodiac victim, and while he later made vague reference to her murder, the killer never fully took credit for it. Handwriting experts had compared his handwriting
确定哪些通信或事件归因于哪一方变得不可能。1967年，河滨市刺杀案受害者雪莉·乔·贝茨的父亲、河滨警方和《新闻企业报》编辑部收到了匿名手写信件，警告会有更多受害者。所有三封信都签有一个类似于字母Z的符号。多年来，人们热烈猜测，有时甚至坚定地认为，这些信件是在“十二宫”采用这个头衔很久之前由他亲笔书写的。这些信件导致人们相信雪莉·乔是第一个“十二宫”受害者，虽然他后来对她的谋杀案做了模糊的提及，但凶手从未完全承认。笔迹专家曾将他的笔迹
to the Sherry Joe Bates letters and concluded they were a match. In 2021, detectives fronting the Sherry Joe Bates case came forward with information they had kept to themselves since 2016. That year, the Riverside Police received an anonymous letter printed from a computer and postmarked from San Bernardino, California. The author claimed to be the person who sent the original handwritten letters following Sherry Joe's murder, warning of more deaths to come. In the newest letter, the author revealed that he was a troubled teen in 1967, and the letters were nothing more than a sick joke. He denied killing Sherry Joe, or being the Zodiac killer.
与雪莉·乔·贝茨的信件进行了比较，并得出结论认为它们是匹配的。2021年，负责雪莉·乔·贝茨案件的侦探们公布了他们自2016年以来一直保密的信息。那一年，河滨警方收到了一封匿名信，由电脑打印，邮戳来自加利福尼亚州圣贝纳迪诺（San Bernardino）。作者声称自己是雪莉·乔遇害后寄出原始手写信件的人，警告会有更多死亡事件发生。在最新的信中，作者透露他1967年时是一个问题少年，这些信件不过是一个恶作剧。他否认杀害了雪莉·乔，也否认自己是“十二宫”杀手。
Investigators confirmed his link to the handwritten notes via DNA recovered from a stamp, and were able to definitively rule him out as being responsible for Sherry Joe's murder. Although the handwritten letters were deemed a hoax, the prankster didn't claim responsibility for the separate typed confession. This typed letter is still considered authentic, given that it contained information that only her killer would know. Riverside investigators have never supported the theory that Sherry Joe Bates was killed by the Zodiac. They had another prime suspect in mind, a former high school acquaintance of Sherry Joe's who came to their attention in 1981. He'd been spotted near the library around the time of
调查人员通过从邮票上回收的DNA证实了他与手写笔记的联系，并能够明确排除他应对雪莉·乔的谋杀负责。尽管手写信件被认为是恶作剧，但那个恶作剧者并没有声称对那封单独的打印自白书负责。这封打印信件仍被认为是真实的，因为它包含了只有凶手才知道的信息。河滨调查人员从未支持雪莉·乔·贝茨是被“十二宫”杀害的理论。他们心中有另一名主要嫌疑人，一名雪莉·乔的高中熟人，他在1981年引起了他们的注意。他曾在案发时被发现出现在图书馆附近，鞋码与犯罪现场发现的脚印相似，并且拥有一块与现场回收的手表类似的手表。
Sherry Joe's murder, wore a similar size shoe to the prints found at the crime scene, and owned a wristwatch like the one recovered there. By mid-1982, detectives were hopeful of arresting this man imminently. But they failed to gather enough evidence, and the suspect's name was never released. Years later, detectives' certainty about this person's involvement was quashed, when advancements in DNA technology confirmed that he wasn't the perpetrator. The only two people known to have directly interacted with the Zodiac no longer talk publicly about the crimes. Shooting survivor Michael Majo struggled with substance abuse and homelessness in the years following his ordeal, while Brian Hartnell, who was stabbed by the
到1982年中期，侦探们曾希望立即逮捕此人。但他们未能收集到足够的证据，嫌疑人的名字也从未公布。多年后，当DNA技术的进步证实他不是肇事者时，侦探们对该人涉案的确定性被打破了。仅有的两名已知与“十二宫”直接互动过的人，现在不再公开谈论这些罪行。枪击幸存者迈克尔·马乔在经历磨难后的几年里一直在与药物滥用和无家可归作斗争，而布莱恩·哈特内尔（Brian Hartnell），他在伯里亚萨湖（Lake Berryessa）被
Zodiac at Lake Berryassa, has chosen not to speak in recent years. In March 2008, Brian spoke to Inland Empire Magazine about his decision to cease talking, saying, There were two reasons why I quit giving interviews. One, everything that could be said had been said. And the second reason was the Zodiac was a publicity hound. If I'm out there giving interviews, talking, keeping my face in the news, I'm taking the attention away from him. He may view that as a threat to him and decide to eliminate the competition. In 2018, a genealogy website was used to identify a prolific serial rapist and killer known as the Golden State Killer, whose crimes were covered in episode 53 of Case File.
“十二宫”刺伤，近年来选择不再发声。2008年3月，布莱恩在接受《内陆帝国杂志》（Inland Empire Magazine）采访时谈到了他停止交谈的决定，他说：“我停止接受采访有两个原因。第一，该说的都已经说了。第二个原因是‘十二宫’是一个渴望曝光的人。如果我一直在外面接受采访、谈话、让我的脸出现在新闻里，我就是在抢他的风头。他可能会认为这对他构成威胁，并决定消除竞争对手。”2018年，一个家谱网站被用来识别一名被称为“金州杀手”（Golden State Killer）的多产连环强奸犯和杀手，其罪行在《案件档案》第53集中有所报道。
After the perpetrator's arrest, an increasing number of law enforcement agencies began turning to genealogy databases to help with criminal investigations. Investigators have confirmed that the potential DNA samples collected from Zodiac crime scenes and documents have been sent to a private lab in the hopes a full genetic profile can be created. If successful, they will be able to run it through genealogy databases in the hopes of linking the Zodiac to a relative. Even if the killer is deceased, a match could still be made and the case could finally be closed. The database grows bigger every year and technology continues to improve, increasing the possibility that the Zodiac will one day be identified.
在肇事者被捕后，越来越多的执法机构开始转向家谱数据库以协助刑事调查。调查人员已证实，从“十二宫”犯罪现场和文件中收集的潜在DNA样本已送往私人实验室，希望能够建立完整的基因图谱。如果成功，他们将能够通过家谱数据库进行比对，希望能将“十二宫”与亲属联系起来。即使凶手已经去世，仍然可以进行匹配，案件最终可能会结案。数据库每年都在增长，技术也在不断进步，增加了“十二宫”终有一天会被查明的可能性。
Despite the lack of answers, one of the smaller remaining mysteries surrounding the Zodiac killer was unexpectedly solved in December 2020. Two computer programmers and a mathematician decided to try their hand at cracking the Zodiac's 340 cipher from 1969. It had been sent just weeks after a man identified only as Sam called into the Jim Dunbar television show claiming to be the Zodiac. Using code-breaking software that one of the men had created, they tested 650,000 possible solutions through a system of trial and error. Finally, after months of attempts, some interesting words emerged. Hope you were trying to catch me was the first phrase. Or the gas chamber was the second.
尽管缺乏答案，但围绕“十二宫”杀手的较小谜团之一在2020年12月意外得到了解决。两名程序员和一名数学家决定尝试破解“十二宫”1969年的340密码。它是在一名仅被称为“萨姆”（Sam）的男子致电吉姆·邓巴（Jim Dunbar）电视节目声称自己是“十二宫”几周后寄出的。利用其中一人开发的破译软件，他们通过反复试验测试了65万种可能的解决方案。最终，经过几个月的尝试，一些有趣的词出现了。“希望你在试图抓住我”是第一个短语。“或者毒气室”是第二个。
Soon, the man had solved the entire message. It read, I hope you are having lots of fun in trying to catch me. That wasn't me on the TV show, which brings up a point about me. I am not afraid of the gas chamber, because it will send me to paradise all the sooner, because I now have enough slaves to work for me. Where everyone else has nothing when they reach paradise, so they are afraid of death. I am not afraid, because I know that my new life is life will be an easy one in paradise, death. Like previous Zodiac correspondence, the word paradise had been misspelled with a C instead of an S. Overall, the code-breaking trio were disheartened by the message they had managed
很快，那个人破解了整条信息。内容是：“我希望你在试图抓住我时玩得很开心。电视节目上的那个人不是我，这引出了关于我的一点。我不怕毒气室，因为它会让我更快地进入天堂，因为我现在有足够的奴隶为我工作。当其他人到达天堂时一无所有，所以他们害怕死亡。我不害怕，因为我知道我的新生活在天堂里会很容易，死亡。”像之前的“十二宫”通信一样，“天堂”（paradise）一词被拼错了，用C代替了S。总的来说，这三位破译者对他们设法破解的信息感到沮丧
to crack 51 years after it was sent. It contained no revelation about the killer's identity. One of the code-breakers, David Oranchak, told the New York Times that he didn't see how the solution would be helpful to the victim's loved ones. Quote, The message in that cipher, I don't see it as being helpful to them. It's more of the same junk that the killer liked to write about. It's just intended to hurt people and to make them afraid. An enduring mystery about the Zodiac is his number of victims. By the time he stopped taunting people, the killer had claimed to have killed 37 people. Police have only attributed five murders to the Zodiac. David Faraday, 17, Betty Lou Jensen,
在寄出51年后。它没有包含关于凶手身份的任何启示。其中一名破译者大卫·奥兰查克（David Oranchak）告诉《纽约时报》，他看不出这个解决方案对受害者的亲人有什么帮助。引用：“那个密码里的信息，我不认为对他们有帮助。这更多是凶手喜欢写的那些垃圾。它只是为了伤害人们，让他们感到恐惧。”关于“十二宫”的一个持久谜团是他的受害者人数。当他停止嘲弄人们时，凶手声称已经杀害了37人。警方仅将五起谋杀案归因于“十二宫”。17岁的大卫·法拉第、16岁的贝蒂·卢·詹森、
16, Darlene Farron, 22, Cecilia Shepard, 22, and Paul Stein, 29. To this day, the murder of Sherry Joe Bates remains unsolved. Other unsolved cases throughout California have since been examined for possible Zodiac links. The 1962 shooting murder of cab driver Ray Davis in Oceanside bears striking similarities to Paul Stein's murder and featured a killer who made taunting phone calls to police before and after the fact. The 1963 shooting murders of Robert Dominguez and Linda Edwards in Gaviota were also highlighted as a possible Zodiac crime, due to it involving a young couple at a beach. Robert and Linda were restrained with pre-cut rope, much like Cecilia Shepard and Brian Hartnell
22岁的达琳·法伦、22岁的塞西莉亚·谢泼德（Cecilia Shepard）和29岁的保罗·斯坦。时至今日，雪莉·乔·贝茨的谋杀案仍未侦破。加利福尼亚州各地的其他悬案此后也被审查，以寻找可能的“十二宫”联系。1962年出租车司机雷·戴维斯（Ray Davis）在欧申赛德（Oceanside）被枪杀的案件与保罗·斯坦的谋杀案有着惊人的相似之处，凶手在案发前后都曾向警方打过嘲弄电话。1963年罗伯特·多明格斯（Robert Dominguez）和琳达·爱德华兹（Linda Edwards）在加维奥塔（Gaviota）被枪杀的案件也被强调为可能的“十二宫”罪行，因为它涉及海滩上的一对年轻夫妇。罗伯特和琳达被预先剪好的绳子捆绑，就像塞西莉亚·谢泼德和布莱恩·哈特内尔
at Lake Berryessa. But unlike the latter, Robert and Linda managed to escape and were gunned down while fleeing. Their assailant is believed to have also been armed with a knife. In both crimes, the perpetrator ordered the female to tie up her male companion at gunpoint. Brian Hartnell recalled the Zodiac had tested and tightened his restraints, which could be interpreted as a precautionary measure he might have learned from a previous failed attempt. Eight months later, newlyweds Johnny and Joyce Swindle were gunned down by the sea in Ocean Beach. All of these crimes share remarkable similarities, including the fact that they were seemingly random and motive-less. More recently, law enforcement has
在伯里亚萨湖一样。但与后者不同的是，罗伯特和琳达设法逃脱，但在逃跑时被枪杀。据信他们的袭击者也携带了一把刀。在这两起犯罪中，肇事者都命令女性在枪口下捆绑她的男性同伴。布莱恩·哈特内尔回忆说，“十二宫”测试并收紧了他的束缚，这可以被解释为他可能从之前失败的尝试中吸取的预防措施。八个月后，新婚夫妇约翰尼（Johnny）和乔伊斯·斯温德尔（Joyce Swindle）在海洋海滩（Ocean Beach）被枪杀。所有这些罪行都有显著的相似之处，包括它们似乎是随机且无动机的。最近，执法部门已经
considered whether these crimes detailed in episode one of this series could have been committed by the Zodiac before he adopted the title. While there is enough to hint that these crimes might be where the serial killer's origin story begins, opinions remain divided. Of the many people suspected for several of these crimes is an unidentified man known only as Sandy. Sandy is a fake name used by a transient young man and petty criminal who came to the attention of police in 1963 after stabbing a man to death during a robbery. He was known to wear military clothing and a pair of black, thick-rimmed eyeglasses. Sandy desired, above all else, to obtain a gun. He has never been located. Composite sketches of Sandy bear a striking
考虑这些在本系列第一集中详细描述的罪行是否可能是“十二宫”在采用该头衔之前所犯下的。虽然有足够的线索暗示这些罪行可能是连环杀手起源故事的开始，但意见仍然存在分歧。在许多被怀疑犯下其中几起罪行的人中，有一个仅被称为“桑迪”（Sandy）的身份不明男子。桑迪是一个流浪青年和轻罪犯使用的假名，他在1963年因在抢劫中刺死一名男子而引起警方注意。他以穿着军装和戴着一副黑色厚框眼镜而闻名。桑迪最渴望得到一把枪。他从未被找到。桑迪的合成素描与
similarity to sketches of the Zodiac. Some have speculated that Sandy may have been responsible for killing Robert Dominguez and Linda Edwards and that their deaths marked the beginning of the Zodiac's attacks. On June 26, 1963, an open letter to the unidentified killer known as Sandy was published in the Lompoc Record. While Sandy may have no connection at all to the Zodiac case, the words delivered a powerful message that could have been written especially for the unidentified serial killer as well. The letter read, If you are guilty, you will pay, even if you remain free and continue to run for many years. Guilt has a way of weighing heavily upon a man, often more heavily than all the retribution a court can exact. So if you continue to run,
“十二宫”的素描惊人地相似。一些人推测，桑迪可能应对杀害罗伯特·多明格斯和琳达·爱德华兹负责，他们的死亡标志着“十二宫”袭击的开始。1963年6月26日，《隆波克记录报》（Lompoc Record）发表了一封致被称为桑迪的身份不明杀手的公开信。虽然桑迪可能与“十二宫”案件完全没有联系，但这些文字传达了一个强有力的信息，也可以说是专门为这位身份不明的连环杀手写的。信中写道：“如果你有罪，你就会付出代价，即使你仍然逍遥法外并继续逃亡多年。内疚感会沉重地压在一个人的心头，往往比法院能施加的所有惩罚都要沉重。所以如果你继续逃跑，
you must forever move with this shadow lurking behind you, blocking all your attempts to gain peace and happiness. I am sure you have heard the old saying, let your conscience be your guide. Well, it is just as true that your conscience can be your hell, unless you find a way to make peace with it. All of these troubles you will find within yourself in that place known as your soul. But you face other problems too. Every place you turn for food, work, money, in sickness or in need of any sort will mean a fight. You will have to fight the fear within you, for you will be afraid that they know and will tell. One day, somewhere along the road, you will stop and think, and then you will know that for all
你必须永远带着这个潜伏在你身后的阴影移动，阻挡你获得平静和幸福的所有尝试。我相信你一定听过那句老话，让你的良心成为你的向导。好吧，同样真实的是，你的良心可以成为你的地狱，除非你找到与它和解的方法。所有这些麻烦你都会在你自己内心那个被称为灵魂的地方找到。但你也面临其他问题。你转向食物、工作、金钱、疾病或任何形式的需求的每一个地方都意味着一场战斗。你将不得不与内心的恐惧作斗争，因为你会害怕他们知道并会说出来。有一天，在路上的某个地方，你会停下来思考，然后你会知道，在所有
of the time you have been running, you have been in a prison of your own making. One likely far worse than any devised by modern justice. And one built by you, because you did not find the courage to clear your name or to face the responsibilities of your own actions. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你逃亡的时间里，你一直身处自己建造的监狱中。这可能远比现代司法设计的任何监狱都要糟糕。这是你自己建造的，因为你没有勇气洗清自己的名字或面对自己行为的责任。”本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。